It's
limited and there is a
zero tolerance policy
or disruption.
[inaudible]
Dr. Jordan Peterson.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
thank you very
much.
Appreciate
to be here at this beautiful.
So I'm going to talk to you tonight.
Suffering from some trepidation
regards for this talk is
probably the most difficult
of the talks that I give
and take.
It's,
it's basing on
much of the material and I'm going to
discuss with you tonight in room 60 12
rules for like which is put your house
in perfect order before you criticize the
world and it's constantly and
the discussion that surrounds it,
is it
a problem that I interned to Seoul for
very little time and sold means two
things.
It needs to clearly formulate girl,
which is actually the most difficult
part of solving the problem.
Once you,
once you can formulate the problem,
it's fairly easy to lay on possibilities,
but to clearly communicate
the problem is very difficult.
It doesn't mean solving
isn't necessarily easy,
but
so,
so to solve that problem
needs to formulate,
but also they need to to articulate it
the problem deeply enough so that in
principle it might go away.
You know,
if you have an argument
with someone in your family,
your or your husband or the sibling,
there's a real conflict around it.
If you formulated conflict
properly and you walked through it,
then you don't have to have to
fight anymore because you've,
you've negotiated a settlement,
the problem disappears and
that's actually how you moved.
If you understand something is
that the problem disappears.
That takes care of principle.
And so the problem that I want to talk
to you about tonight is I want to make a
product specific.
I spent a lot of time thinking
about totalitarianism in,
I'm very interested in both of those
topics interested in ideological
possession,
but I'm more interested in something
that's the most extreme variant of
physiological possession and see it.
And that's the proclivity of people
to use unbelievably brutal means of
enforcing.
It carries to the ideology because
etiology in itself is a mystery.
Why can't we believe the fix that they do,
but why they're willing to use,
why they're willing to commit atrocities
in the service of those ideologies is a
bunch of deeper history.
And one of the stories that
really affected me when I
was studying what happened
in Nazi Germany and indigo light counts
of the Soviet Union because those were
the two forms of massive trust,
let's say that I dealt into intervals
deeply was a story that never really left
my imagination.
This was a story or something that was
inflicted upon my prisoners in our shorts
during the time of the
Nazi concentration camps.
Do you understand that?
Something like that,
you kind of have to put yourself there.
You know,
and that's an uncomfortable thing
to do for all sorts of reasons.
You can put yourself there as victim,
which is actually more
comfortable and get some sense.
I mean it's not,
but it's comforting,
but your option is basically
victim or perpetrator,
right?
Take a situation like that.
I think it's easier for people
to imagine themselves as victim.
It's not that that's easy cause it's not,
it's a paragraph to attempt,
but it's nowhere near as error.
Generally speaking as it is to
hazard herself a perpetrator.
You might not be willing to do that,
but that's actually a mistake because
unless you're willing to think that the
sorts of people who perpetrated
the catastrophes of Nazi
Germany and the Stella
was Soviet Union and I was China,
Cambodia,
et Cetera,
we thought we added including North Korea,
including now then is the way that this
neighbor and that means that the people
who do it aren't a different species
that you then are the same and I don't
really think that we're ever going to
be able to stop that sort of thing so it
can be stopped and interviewed the case
without reading those situations as if
we're the perpetrators and that's
a terrible thing to do and fucking,
I don't think that there's any way would
the situation without understanding
that.
One of the things I often encourage my
students can understand when they're
contemplating history and reading history
is that they stop reading history like
it's something that happened in the
past and start reading like it's an
autobiography because
it's much more effective.
You're a historical creature.
When you read about history,
when you read history you are grieving
about now you might not know that because
you're not every form of human.
You could be like your
whatever particular form.
Huge choke right here,
right now about you have the potential,
but the ending for a
multiplicity of beings,
I think it was Alexander Pope who said,
if I remember correctly,
nothing human is foreign.
To me that's a hell of a statement.
On the upside it's really quite something
because there's obviously deep great
people,
but on the downside it's
reading something to,
and so to develop a detailed
self understanding is to
develop an understanding
that enables you to,
to,
to understand what your
affiliation with the,
with the Nazi camp guards.
And that's a very unpleasant thing.
So the situation with Asha,
let's say it was,
people were brought
there often in Cali cars,
often in either freezing weather or in
very hot butter and they're all crammed
together in cattle car standing mostly
as many people as they possibly be
crammed in.
And what that meant was many
of them died on the way there.
They die of heat exhaustion or they
froze to death if they are on the outer
sides of the car or they suffocate or,
and so it's always,
it's very difficult to lens and
how terrible that has to be.
And then of course they
arrived at accounts and they
were sorted into people who
from whom some useful labor
might conceivably be extracted
or those who were due
to a relatively immediate death.
And then that's all bad enough,
you know,
for sure.
I mean these people were innocent to
begin with and then they were separated
under brutal conditions from their,
from their life.
And so from their past and
the present feminists future,
absolutely traumatizing.
The families were destroyed,
everything was taken away from them.
They were treated as badly as animals are
treated when they're treated badly and
then,
and they were brought to these
accounts and the counselor.
Cute places like the size of small cities.
Can you think of cow weight to the city?
But really that's what they were.
But that wasn't enough for
the people who ran an account,
which is really something because you
think that would be enough no matter how
what we're motivated by,
you might think that
that would do the trick,
you know fundamentally,
but it really didn't do the trick.
You know there there was a sign over
Auschwitz which was stolen last year.
Take this side assisted and maybe in
many barriers as if there was only one of
them and I can't say the German
or something like perfect connect.
Free maturely is lacking
but it needs work.
We'll set it free.
That was the little model,
the account.
That's also really stuck in
my mind because it was a joke.
No,
it's actually a chill.
It's really something to think of a mind
that would conceptualize that Jill and
put it in that sort of place.
Work rules free camp.
It was designed to work people to death.
Not even for the work they didn't do.
No,
because if the Nazis would've had any
sense and if they wouldn't be motivated by
what they say they would,
we're motivated by,
they would just said the cap itself.
In a much more humane manner.
They would have used the people,
they put in accounts as slaves to further
the war effort and they might've won
the war,
but that isn't what they did.
They brought them to Jews and the
Gypsies and all the other people.
They decided where we're worth
having around each of the couch.
He just basically work the point to be
the death and the reason for that was
because that was the way
you can make the depth.
The worst.
It could be the hope because they
usually work as a punishment.
You don't if you work utility work.
Soldiered isn't talked
about this as a ghoulag.
When he was there,
he said,
well at least,
but he was laying bricks as a prisoner.
He had the Grad gratification,
let's say if they need to build
a straight wall of bricks,
like there was something about productive
Labor that he's engaging in productive
Labor that they need to find at least
see some tiny shred of useful meaning in
this absolutely dismal,
wretched herder,
a circumstance.
But there were people who were running
the camps like Auschwitz who wanted to
take,
even now the way it worse than that,
convert it.
And so one of the things that the camp
guards used to do to the new prisoners
was to have them pick up wet socks,
wet 100 pounds,
100 pound sacks of went Saul and
then carry them on their backs.
And then you remember I already told
you that these people had already been
through from one side of
that account to the other.
But that wasn't enough either.
Even though there was no reason you
can move the soul and it was only a
demonstration of power,
demonstration of the sub,
absolute subjugation of
the prisoners to this,
what would you call it?
Universal human necessity for work.
We have to work,
right?
It's one of the curses God glazed
donuts at the end of the story about me.
People have deployed and you can
find meaning in that inverted,
it becomes a torture and you
do that by making it pointless,
difficult appointments.
So the carrier that sacral quit
salt from one side of the camp,
how resolve PC,
a parody of work and that was what
the joke referred to parody of work.
But that wasn't enough either.
They had good cherry back.
Right.
You think there's a
real part of the screen,
the same artist that came up with a joke.
There's something about that that system,
it's almost dark and that would
be trained to understand that.
Why is that exactly?
It's not like it's a question
it's gone up with vote.
Although it's a question when
people don't like to ask or answer,
you know,
in your country and in mine,
um,
we have this spectacle of the mass murder.
It's a competitive game that often
young men played and you know,
I call it the game for good reason.
That competitive game for good reason
that the mass murders school shooters,
those sorts of people that
keep track of each other.
Now they tried to up the engine.
Each cap,
the most egregious should have was
probably the one at Sandy Hook I would say
for the elementary school
kids who are killed.
Because that brings up
another level of mystery.
It's like why go after the innocence?
If you're altered for her revenge,
why not punish the guilty and sort of
that because it's more effective to punish
the innocent because
it's more of a violation.
It's a greater violation of good,
let's say it's,
it's,
it's a more evil and it's,
it's a more vegetable active,
you know,
perhaps the most data sets of the innocent
might be elementary school children,
especially ones that you don't know.
And so the killer of
the sandy hook killer,
something like he didn't
think this through.
Right.
And that's another thing to consider.
You don't get to the point where you to
do something like that on a win already
taking months,
months,
months or even years of dark fantasizing
before you get to that point.
And you can go places that are hardly
imaginable when you allow yourself to be
taken over by the kind of spirit
that produces that kind of fantasy.
Right.
And where do you go?
It's a place where you think that
bringing them a deadly weapon into an
elementary school and deliberately
targeted it is the children,
is,
is actually a goal that's
reasonable to pursuit.
Now you see this most recently,
very recently in Toronto or a band who
was apparently frustrated by his lack of
success in the dating market,
or at least that was the,
excuse me,
the accused rented a van and jump
on the sidewalk 12 off on sidewalks,
which is very long time,
right?
It's not a casual,
aggressive,
impulsive women Christmas years.
Your hand on the steering wheel in your
hands because you're angry and you see a
crowd of people.
It's not fat.
It's,
it's,
it's very,
very deliberate.
And to hit people one by one,
you know when it continual
sequence like that.
And then I talked to a journalist who had
seen this man the next day when he was
raped in court.
She said that he walked into the courtroom
like someone who was there for board.
And so,
so there's this constellation of action.
I think that the only proper way to
describe those options is as evil actions.
That is a metaphysical statement,
some sense because you describe it,
the options as equal as to
also with simultaneously
proclaim the reality of good
and evil in the world.
But that doesn't really bother me
because I can't see that there's any
alternative language.
It's useful to describe
those sorts of advances.
I mean you might not agree with that.
You might take of,
you might not think that
that's the appropriate by
imagine within which to close
such events.
I do the appropriate language.
And that being said,
in order to understand those events,
you have to speak a
language with good and evil.
And I do believe this to be true
and I can tell you why in part,
one of the things that's happened to me,
I didn't lecture online the distinction
between tragedy and evil and I think
he's one of the most effective
but the directly liberty.
Um,
I started to say brigade,
I would conceptually
earthquakes and cancer,
you know the standard
catastrophes of life,
that CPP perpetrator,
acts of God so to speak and very hard
on people obviously and often Danthony
from the level of attacks which are
deadening in the same manner and you might
think therefore the same thing.
They're not the same thing.
Their tragedy is one thing and malevolence
is another thing and the level of
tragedies,
but worst of things,
and we actually don't as
clinicians if we're awake,
has clinical all of those because one
of the things that it's quite well
documented in the claim in the literature
is what causes post traumatic stress
disorder and generally speaking,
it isn't exposure to tragedies
that caused this poster and
usually what goes as close to
his exposure to malevolence.
So not only do you have to be heard,
let's say you have to be hurt by
someone who is intended for now.
That's what I'm very,
the other variance of this often happens
to soldiers going to bow down and they
observe themselves in something that's
deeply malevolent and they never knew
that they had been asking for that perhaps
does partner in that even enjoys it,
at least in the moment logo and
afterwards they're fragmented by the
consequences.
Say people who were
perhaps somewhat too naive,
he can make effective soldiers.
Um,
they observe themselves doing something
terrible that the battlefield and then
they're broken and they
cannot be repaired.
And I've had many heart,
it's very difficult for
them to be repaired.
And I've had many people like that contact
me and say that because of the watch,
this lecture hall,
the Distinction Between Tragedy and evil,
they have been able to recover at least
in part from the post traumatic stress
disorder.
And so,
and in my own clinical practice,
when I treated people,
I had a client who was a young woman
and she had been bullied very badly.
Buddy boy who she did not want to go out
with it after that made it his life's
work to bring her down when she get
very effectively with his friends and he
pulled her into a state
of absolute psychosis.
When I first saw her,
she couldn't even speak
and she was hallucinating.
She had an auditory and
visual hallucinations and
I could barely communicate
with her.
I spent about eight months with her slowly
detailing out what happened and what
have really affected her was the fact
that she couldn't understand how anyone
could be so cruel as to bloat the way to
do nothing but make her life miserable.
And that's what broke
her and she was real.
It was really serious.
And we had to sit and talk.
First of all,
I tried to carry ways of then as she
recovered in increasingly coherent ways
about good and evil,
essentially about the fact that people
can be motivated to pursue nothing.
That disruption and pain and misery and
to do that consciously and with intent
accidentally and at that as,
as the victims of some other process,
you know,
but knowing full well what they're doing
it and doing it because they know what
they're doing.
And she was a lot more mature,
let's say at the end of that process
that she was at the beginning of April,
she paid great crisis,
which is typically the case.
So I do understand that.
I do understand what sort of language is
necessary for use to frame these sorts
of situations.
And um,
and I think the language of good
and evil is the appropriate leg,
which you aren't treating the topic we
sufficient seriousness unless you need to
use the appropriate terminology and evil.
To me it's something like the generation
of harm for the sake of the harm,
especially to think about it
as a condiment dispensing it.
And you can understand that if you
think about the side dimension,
we're pro second freak.
There's and this authentic to that.
It's a dramatic or artistic statement
painted in blood essentially.
And people don't like that idea
because we don't make fleet.
You know,
we like to think that
the only cause of human
inappropriate human action,
like people just do better.
They wouldn't do it.
And it's like I'm afraid
that just doesn't cut it.
People know perfectly well what you're
doing and that's exactly why you're doing
it.
I mean there are secrets involved,
it's involved in everything and it's
just not sufficient explanation.
So the question is where do you go when
you use language is put an evil and
that's associated with another question,
which is something like what's
the proper level of analysis?
Because as I mentioned it to begin with,
it's very difficult to,
to solve a problem formulating property.
So the question here,
I think that
the emerging question
is what could happen?
What else do you use
to approach the issue?
And I would say there
is a deeper question.
The question of human motivations
are equal except perhaps the opposite
question,
which is human motivation for good.
I've heard the same thing in some sense,
right?
It does.
If you pause it one,
you will also be positive.
It's opposite it dark you incident
because of like taking poison evil.
You are the opposite of that.
There's no way around that.
So it's the same question and I'm going
to be the question I suppose suppose of
ethical behavior of morale,
something like that in the question,
the question of this nature,
the nature of reality in the world.
It's a deep question.
You could say it's the deepest,
deepest question and it
requires formulation at the
deepest possible level of
analysis and it's a mystery that requires
formulation at the deepest possible
level of analysis.
And so you accept that it's a history
of you except that it's a deep just left
one and I'm assistant.
Didn't you ask yourself,
where did you go to find an answer to
a question that's mysterious at the
deepest possible level of analysis and
down to that at least the partners you go
or you don't,
you go over,
you don't know.
You go to that place that you don't know.
There's actually a technical,
that's a technical issue in some sense.
So one of the things that
currently only pointed out,
and I think this is well supported by the
relevant neuro psychological and neuro
psychiatric literature,
is that your dreams and your fantasies
contain the information that you don't
yet know.
Now,
that's not an easy thing to understand
that because you might think,
let's say you have to three,
you figure out what the dream means.
Then there's a mystery,
which is,
well,
if you didn't know what to treat them,
how the hell did you dream it?
Right?
Mean because you drunk,
you don't understand it.
So how does that work?
Because how can you think of
something that you don't understand?
Part of the army,
you're not exactly a unity.
There's parts of you that know things
that other parts of you don't know.
Or there's parts of you that know things
in ways that the part of you that parks
can understand that.
And there's things that you act out
that are too complicated for you to
represent for it to articulate.
And so there's lots of things that were,
that you don't understand
that our adolescent foreman,
I mean,
you know,
you don't know how you breathe,
you don't know what in your heart works.
It's not support how your heart beats.
You don't have voluntary
control over that.
So it's not that surprising in some sense
that your mind could produce contents
that transcend your articulate.
No idea was that,
that's what dreams did that
with what dreams were doing,
ascension was you haven't worldview
and that worldview was only partial
obviously,
because what the hell,
you know,
so you know,
you're,
you're limited in your knowledge
and you're articulate and you're,
and you're,
you're,
you're logical.
It integrated,
articulate knowledge
as the limited domain.
And there's lots of things that
exist outside that made those,
it takes,
you don't understand or
errors that you've made.
And you also have to cope with them half
to start provisionally understanding
them.
Because not only do you have to understand
what you understand and most will
have to come to understand
what you don't yet understand.
Right?
And that's how you learn and
it's August how that happens.
And Hume's idea was that
this is an elaboration I came
to some degrees while you
learned in part by acting and then you
learn in part by representing that action
and you learn by analyzing
this representation.
And I would say yoga is not particularly
well regardless in most cases by
modern,
more biologically oriented
psychologists and medical practitioners.
But that's generally because they don't
understand what the hell he was talking
about.
So the reason is there's good news,
psychiatric evidence now,
psychological evidence that that's
actually how the brain functions.
So there is a neuropsychologist,
they'll Conan Goldberg who was a student
of another neuropsychologist named
Alexander Luria,
who's a Russian,
probably the grade school psychologist
of the 20th century is he basically laid
the ground water.
My understanding of the way the brain
functions and his students discovered
extraordinarily fundamental
neurophysiological fact
spoke to Brady's heavy
hitter and his student help.
Conan Bloomberg was very interested
in why we have two hemispheres.
It's not obvious what
have to have a seriously.
It's as as we have two
brains and there is evidence.
There was surgery that was government,
not so much anymore but years ago when
people had intractable epilepsy that
caused the two hemispheres stuff,
Corpus Callosum,
which is the fat tissue,
proper hemispheres and collecting,
discovered
conscious and so it's
actually the case in,
in you,
in your feed you have to consciousness
is that someone separate that you'd be
the case that each have had
various functions and what
that implies is that you
need to look at the world in two ways
and that implies maybe that the world is,
is in some sense fundamentally divisible
into two because otherwise why would
have you evolved the brain then we'd look
at it in two ways since you evolve to
actively avoid hitting the world and it's
not just you because animals have two
hemispheres as well as a very fundamental
division and what Goldberg's suggested
was that your left hemisphere
of a specialized for
operation in places that you
understand in your right hemisphere was
specialized for operation in places that
you don't understand,
find.
You can think about that if you want to
think about it from a more biological
perspective.
You could say that you have one system,
say psychological system that
orients you unexplored territory,
which is where your things are familiar
and where you can predict what's going
to happen,
where what you want to happen is happening
because that's the best definition of
being comfortable,
right?
You know,
you know where you are when you act and
what you want to have happen happens.
That's a place that's home that's
explored territory and what an unexplored
territory is.
The space,
the on account fire,
let's say the darkness of
the night in the jungle,
but also that place where things that
you didn't know what to expect or want
happened and he's the best.
So that's what the world is composed of,
the substance of the
world have experienced.
It's all those things that you want to
have happen that you're familiar with and
all those things that
go bump in the night.
All those things that rise up out
of the unknown to disrupt your,
the best laid plans of mice,
let's say.
And so you do have these two separate
neurological systems in the way.
And so that was outlined.
Oil foaming Goldberg quite nicely and uh,
it's been verified by neurosis
neuropsychiatric status.
For example,
by MDGs Rep Shaundra who's
a neurologist at Ucla.
I'll tell you a story about that,
but he discovered,
cause it's pretty damn amazing.
So there's this neurological
condition called neglect.
I said,
really strange condition.
It's virtually in comprehensible.
And what happens if you have eucalyptus
that you have a stroke and you're right,
the bridle up the right priority
area of your right hemisphere has,
right?
It doesn't happen if
it's left hemispheres.
And what happens if you have that stroke
is you lose the logic side of your
body.
And the loss is extremely interesting
that the first thing is you lose motor
control so you can't move it.
But that's sort of the beginning of it.
You lose your ability to conceptualize it.
The fact that you had the left
side of your body and more,
you lose the ability to conceive of land.
And we don't know how this happens.
I think it must be something like,
you know,
if I stand here and look out at all,
I can see that people right
in front of me quite clearly,
and then the people to my right and left,
as long as I keep my eyes fixed,
it's right in front of me.
They're quite blurry.
I can't see their faces,
although I know there people.
And then by this are out at the
periphery of my visual system.
I don't even have color vision anymore.
Even white tape it door cause the tests
to show that and then past that which is
behind me.
There's nothing,
it's not black.
It's not an amputee,
it's just not there.
It's not even,
it's not even gone.
Fair.
It just doesn't exist.
And what seems to happen when people who
have neglect that moves around a three
quarters of that thing instead of half.
Now that's a guess because
we really don't know.
But if you get people who
they'd like to draw a clock,
it will put all the numbers in one half.
And if you give them a plate full of food,
they'll only eat the food off
the right side of the plate.
And if you turn the plate,
they'll eat half of what's left.
And then even more strangely now,
I meant they notice that they have a
left heart and it really upsets them.
So they have it and they noticed they
have a left arm and they'll try to,
it will be horrified by it.
They'll think in someone else's,
they'll take maybe someone that they know
or that maybe the nurses left the body
and sometimes they'll even
try to throw it out with bed.
And so and so they don't seem to buy.
And here's the other thing,
strange is they're not upset about the
fact that they're half paralyzed as
because they actually don't
know that they're half parallax.
And the reason for that,
the part of the brain that would alert
them to the fact that they're half
paralyzed is being
destroyed by the stroke.
So it's,
it's there,
don't have sex at all.
Like that part that would make them
upset because you should be upset if you
lose half your voice.
It's like that's very upsetting.
And the fact that you get upset is your,
it alerts you to the importance of the
loss and so mad that he didn't care a
little bit.
Well then would you notice
and answered as well?
Apparently not.
And so what grandma Sean was
experimented with the balance,
literally the balance of
people who have neglected.
He did this weird little experiments
that you do to test people's vestibular
system,
which enables them to
stay on break felons,
consultant.
If you pour cold water in someone's ear,
then it upstairs,
I have sense of their buildings because
your ears are intensely involved in your
balance and your eyes are move back
and forth and it destabilizes the seas.
And so around the Shaundra was
testing his neglect cases for their,
for their,
uh,
for their testicular
function using cold water.
A number of them woke up and
realized that they were paralyzed.
And his idea was
essentially that the shock,
eventually the shock of the
cold water was enough to,
to increase,
say emotional functioning enough to
reactivate the damage and efforts in the
right hemisphere to wake them up
enough to notice that have to go into
businesses and to produce a catastrophic
emotional response when people realize
what happened.
Um,
so if you call the attention
of someone with neglect,
the left hand and you say,
you haven't left handed there,
and we said,
can you move it?
And they'll say,
well,
never mind.
I don't feel like my arthritis
is point this morning.
It hurts me.
They come up with some rationalization
for why they can't move it,
but they're not upset.
So robichon none when
you're getting your ears.
And then they wake up and they haven't
had a strong emotional response to the
loss of the live side of your body.
But then 20 minutes later they snap out
of it and then they forget they lost the
left.
They go right back to
their old way of thinking.
Now,
what's so interesting about this and how
it's related to whatever he told you is
that,
see,
their left hemisphere had already
built a blog with their body,
and you know you have
a model of your body.
It's really [inaudible].
You can tell that magic
if you break a tooth,
what happens if you break your tooth is
your tongue grooves absolutely insane,
right?
Next three months,
all of your tongue does
is poke around in there.
Pick her up exactly the
contours of your mouth,
and maybe it takes you three
months to update that too.
And you don't feel like
you're both is a stranger.
And the reason for that is
what you should let him know.
It's in your outrage.
Like entire,
you're unbelievably are not sensitive.
And so because when you put things
in there and you have to eat,
and so you have the intelligence of
what's you and what isn't for you.
Choose your tongue.
Like,
I mean,
it's very important to
have that map that you see.
You see with your experience
with having a damage tooth.
You see just how much work it takes to
even do a little tiny bit of remapping,
right?
It's like three months of of Tom,
the effort to update
your will of your mouth.
Imagine how much effort it would lucky
we'll take to update your model of your
body if you've lost half of it,
right?
So that's it.
So your left hemisphere count do that.
It just keeps on processing
your body with the old model.
And since the right hemispheres damaged,
there isn't any emotion
associated with the loss.
And so the left hemisphere just keeps
on grinding away on its own local one.
And that happens to us a lot.
But that's sort of how we think is that
we have these partial models of reality
that more or less work and
were really stubborn about.
And we don't want them to disappear
because they take a bloody modern word to,
to formulate.
And if we're forced to lose the,
it tends to be catastrophic.
And so an example that might be,
you know,
let's say you put a whole bunch of
effort into a monogamous monogamous
relationship and so as she's
lasted 10 years and you think,
well what's the effort?
Okay well the first PBS,
you've gone a lot of places with this
person who had done a lot of things with
them and you have a story about that and
the stories based on your understanding
of that person and the implication of
that understanding for your understanding
of you.
So you know you might be equal.
I took mine,
my wife or husband to Hawaii and we
have a nice time and you have that
whole memory and you have hundreds of
memories like that whole sequence,
the next your story about who you
are and very hard in the past.
And then you have a story like that,
who you are and what maybe we now and
then give a story like that about your
future.
And then you find out what the partners
can been having sequential affairs for
the last 15 years.
And it's like,
well what happens?
Well,
your model's not really delicate.
And then you think,
well,
what does that mean exactly?
Well,
it doesn't just mean that you
don't know who your partner is,
although it really means that it also
means everything is not about your past is
wrong.
All those memories of
everything that happened,
those aren't accurate.
And so when something like
that happens in deep betrayal,
this is why Dante put betrayers
in the lowest level of hell,
by the way,
are besides safety itself in case denies
that the betrayers and because it blows
out your model of the past and
the presence of the teacher,
you told him where your are,
we don't know where you were and
you don't know where you're going.
And it's worse than that.
That because you also don't know who you
are anymore because you are obviously
someone who just wasn't that
awake and you were with someone.
Justin wasn't who you thought they were.
And so it's no wonder you'd be
resistant to information like that.
You know what I mean?
It's like who the hell wants to have a
global theory of that magnitude disprove
dealt a blow?
It just leaves you wide open and exposed
to the world so we can protect your
theories as much as you possibly can.
You're not going to overthrow them because
of some casual disapprove or to stick
to them.
You know,
psychologists talk about
that as a confirmation bias.
Let's say I think about it as a cognitive.
They are,
you know,
bemoan the fact that people are
very stubborn about giving up their
presuppositions,
but it's no bloody wonder.
You know,
it's,
you put a lot of afternoon to
that formulation of the world.
It's not just a representation,
right?
It's the way we live in the world.
And so if you give that up,
well then what the hell
are you supposed to do?
Right?
You're supposed to be enraged.
He's supposed to have a fit,
is supposed to become bourbon.
Russ,
are you supposed to
collapse into depression?
He's supposed to be
like infinitely cynical.
Are you supposed to never happen to have
a relationship that your life are you
supposed to be half complete contempt
for yourself for being so naive and blind
or you're supposed to hate humanity
because it contains the capacity for that
kind of betrayal.
It's like you don't know.
All of those things are true all at
one civil paisley and that's the little
space that you occupy,
right?
That's the mythical
underworld essentially.
That's a place you go when
your dreams and hopes died.
Everyone goes there from time to time.
Lots of people go there
and never come out.
So what did,
what happens when you,
what happens in a situation like that?
What happens when you're faced by
something that you really radically don't
understand?
Partly what happens is you start
fantasizing about who you can partner.
Was it the it's you don't need to be
pumped into all sorts of dramatic theories
about what they might really be.
Number two,
right?
There's pair,
you don't head down them and cynicism,
bitterness and all of that,
but that's your right hemisphere trying
to make a new picture of reality and
generating these fantasies kind of come
up with an account that makes sense of
what happened.
And that's really the way that we help
to cope with radically new information.
Something like that.
Except it's even more complicated.
And I'm telling you all this
because I want to specify how it is,
what I want to specify,
why it's necessary to go to the
deepest level of analysis and to try to
understand what's there.
The more mysterious something is,
the more you have to use your imagination
in some sense to represent it because
you don't know what to do.
Fancy socks and hypothesize
about you have to dream about,
yeah,
oh,
you'll kind of walk this office.
But
dreams
concentrated on what we ignore.
So the part of your brain
tells you what's a lot.
Then he's on things in the normal world,
but that doesn't work perfectly because
what you know doesn't work perfectly.
And so you started recruiting errors
along the way and then your right
hemisphere collects those areas.
It starts to try and figure
out what to do about them.
If you wake people up
under CP and the dreaming,
the most common emotion,
they relate his anxiety and because at
night what you do is try to reconfigure
what you know to take into account what
you don't know and that's an anxiety
provoking process and use notion
with regards to dream analysis.
And that was the same story to
some degree was that you could,
if people were facing an attractable
mystery and they didn't know how to see.
So for example,
then you come and see me,
you're not happy in your job that you
don't want to give it up because of the
security or like it's
complicated situation and you
can't see any way forward.
Then I might say,
well do you dream?
And if you said yes,
some people dream a lot and right now
and we might take a look at dreams to see
if he could catch the new story that's
emerging underneath your knowledge about
where it is that you might go.
And that can be very,
very illuminating and people differ in
the complexity and sophistication of
their drinks and their
ability to remember the,
but we also might bucket your
fantasy so maybe you know,
you have a fantasy about what you really
liked to say to your boss and it's a
fairly well developed from maybe or hit
embarrassed about it because it's kind
of violence.
And
if we let you have that say,
well tell me about the fantasy.
Do you lay it out a fantasy?
We can take weekend at the seeds of who
you might be calm because maybe you're
not standing up for yourself
and not feed your boss.
It's time to retire.
And so you have this fantasy that you're
rooted in the direction that that lays
out the landscape of what look
like.
If you find it just got up enough courage
to march in there and say exactly what
you have to say.
And so that's something you want.
And if you're thinking about changing
careers that we want to figure out what
you want.
And so you can look up what you're
fantasizing about what you want.
And maybe you could find
some seats and what you want.
You might say,
well,
you're not going to be happy in the next
job regardless of what you do unless
you become somewhat more assertive
because he'll just carry the same problem
into your next job.
So getting the problem is the job.
Maybe the problem is do we did knock on
what you really need to do to thrive in
work and you can try
to solve that problem.
And then we started figuring out whether
that would also mean that you would
have to shift careers.
And so that's how you can
use the analysis of say,
fantasies and dreams to shed light on
how it is with the person might conduct
themselves.
Now
this is where it gets tricky.
Casey hasn't got treats.
You can ask him.
Hmm.
Alright.
So here's another way that you figure out
how it happened.
You were,
let's say your your child and
there's a lot you don't know.
So how do you handle that?
Well,
you stay in a simplified environment,
right?
You don't crawl out onto the
street when you're 10 months old,
your parents aren't gonna let you do that.
And they keep you in the phone
and they keep you close to them.
And what you do is react though.
But you know,
which isn't very much.
Mostly it's how quick things in your boat
with an index because that's what she,
that's what kids do.
And just smiling kids
to play a little bit.
But it's a fragile space of
knowledge and it's easily disrupted.
And when it's disrupted,
you cry.
And that's a signal up to the disruption.
And then your parents move in.
If their grade are you all watching,
they fix whatever the problems and what
you do is you watch and then you imitate
me.
So I'm like,
you know what,
the rock could you,
cause you're not sophisticated
enough to know what they're up to.
Heal childhood.
You get to pull the town with
the behavior of the parents.
No parents should give a full
account of her own behavior.
So you certainly can't
expect that from a child.
But children often will obviously grow
up to take care of their own children,
just like grow up to take care of their
own offspring ever knowing what they're
doing.
Exactly.
So you learn by amputation.
And what that means is that collectively
we faced things that we didn't
understand for very,
very long periods of time and we've
figured out how to act so that it works
well.
We don't know.
We don't know the rules
that underlie that.
Exactly.
We don't know exactly what that means.
We just figured it out.
So there was a way of being,
a good partner might say there's
a way to be a good mother.
Mostly you understand what that is
when you fail at it or when your child,
he accuses you of failing at it,
right?
Because he's only in the failure that you
realize that you deviate from whatever
the ideal is cause you're not.
Who the hell knows what
the rules are for beacon?
Good father.
It's very difficult to detail them
but you know when you've failed.
Okay,
so you know how to be a controller and
you know that because you imitated your
father and he imitated his father images.
His father is like way back as
far as you can possibly jolt.
That's the rule.
We also know that and here's,
here's an example of why,
how the clock called colleague at the
University of Toronto who spends some
maternal behavior and racks and racks,
you're actually very sophisticated.
They have somewhat of a cultural state
pass on through imitative learning.
If you take rap cops away from their
mother and and treat them well enough so
that they live in,
which is not that easy by the way,
cause feeding them and giving them enough
water and warmth and so forth isn't
enough.
You also have to attend to them.
You have to touch them.
You played it the more they die anyways.
If you take prep helps away from their
mother and then you let those routes grow
up and have to wrap apps and then those
wrap crops grow up and have red crops,
et cetera.
You find that the maternal behavior
is disruptive for three generations.
So that shows you why you need that
imitative continuity in order to keep
knowledge that's implicit
propagating through a culture.
So once it's disruptive,
it's very difficult to
local once again ask.
So
we've learned how to be good
and bad by trial and error,
very long periods of time.
We've learned that an imaging back from
the people that we see who are good,
the hug,
and we've learned how to embody that.
And so we carry that on
with us in our actions.
Now you actually do this in
quite a sophisticated way,
even though you can't describe it exactly.
So let's say you go to a party and if
someone that gets annoying and they're
annoying because they tell jokes that
aren't funny and they've been off the
lights and conversation and they don't
pay any attention to anyone else,
they're full of micro errors.
That made me socially be tolerable.
And so what they,
what they are doing is easy.
Anything from your implicit ideal,
right?
That's why they're annoying,
obviously,
because they're not eating the
way they should be educated.
And you could tell that
because they're annoying.
And so what that means is that you have
an ideal that you're expecting from
other people over time.
And that isn't the case
because wherever we go,
we meet people and we expect and hope
that they will act out the ideal.
And when they don't,
we know.
But that doesn't mean you can say
what it is cause you can know,
go home with your partner and say,
I was that person.
So annoying.
And You yes if I'm Chad.
But it's hard to specify because you
don't move the ideal that you don't know
exactly what it was to break through.
It's very difficult to
beat this articulate,
but you do have any ideal in mind.
Okay?
So what that means is that we can act
out and conceptualized before we could
describe in words what that ideal he is.
Now this
development,
as they call it,
the junk studied kids 30 gauge.
And that doesn't necessarily sound very
important or just gauged it just for
fun.
But it's really important because the
game is actually a microcosm of the world.
Just what people like cage played.
Monopoly example.
It's a microcosm of no
holds barred capitalism,
let's say.
And you can learn about
your bedroom people,
about people by playing monopoly with
them because even though it's fictional
and the gold is just real people that
adopt the goal was if it's really that he
started to manifest be emotions that
would be relevant and getting a real
pursuit and so that you
can see what they're fun to
play with and if they're fun
to play with and
it'll get a little high
and mighty about winning,
he don't,
they [inaudible] to lock.
They detach themselves from a
little bit so that it stays fun.
Hey,
remember that it's a game,
like they're doing all sorts
of sophisticated things.
If they're funding by Jessica number
that they're trying to play with your
testing,
how well they match deep.
Was that ideal that you will?
And so that's what kids are doing when
they played games with their friends to
their,
it's more complicated
because they also the way,
then again,
just basically that they're pretending.
So let's say kids who frequents the
decides we're going to play hubs.
This is a common kits and Damon,
first thing they do is
have them negotiation.
So unlikely to screen writers.
They say,
well you be the moment you'd be the dad,
you don't need to be the cap and then
if everyone wants to play that role,
but that's the first
thing the kids have hope.
Kids have to want to play
voluntarily or it's not good.
That's a good thing to keep in mind.
So putting accepts the rule
and then you might say,
well then they go ahead and take the
mother and the father and the cap,
but they don't actually think I taped it
because like if I was imitating you sit
exactly like your city,
but I would move my body in
exactly the same where you are.
But if I was caricatured review,
let's say I got to know you a little bit,
then I can kind of adopt the spirit
of your voice and your mannerisms,
whatever they are.
I could extract out from you a pattern
of character and it's giving me an I can
body that pattern that's a lot more
sophisticated and just invitation and not
for the kids are trying to do when they
played house and I'm indicating they're
far down
because they're not doing exactly the
same movements that the I was doing.
They've watched the farther,
either farther over multiple contexts
and they've extracted the commonalities
across those contexts and portrayed
back with the term before that.
You can think about that as a spirit.
It's the spirit of that man.
He before non personal multiple context
and then they're acting that out there
representing that good boy and he hit
dramatic play and so they can't say what
they're doing and they can't
tell you what the rules are,
but they can use their
own body to represent this
incredibly complex thing that
they don't understand.
And they can do the
same thing with mother,
right?
If you play with a goal and feed it
and do all the things for the mother
doesn't,
they can practice being a mother and so
then they learn how to embody this ideal
without describing it.
Now there's a lot of things that we know
like that and so we know how to act out
things that you don't understand it now.
Eventually we figured out
what collectively over the
tens of thousands of years
that you've been trying
to figure things out,
how to act in a manner that makes us
essentially sig the signature of civilize
the neighbor's or somebody's
sick in this group,
even though we don't know each
other and to all do the same thing,
all the dog,
the same posture and to oligarchs
essentially the same attitude and the same
emotional state and to thereby being
predictable to one another and to be safe
with one another,
which is what we're doing right now.
It's a ritual.
Everyone understands his
a theatrical Richard,
that everyone understands it and the fact
that everyone is doing the same thing,
it means that we can all be virtually
assured that at the moment we're all
holding the same ideal and that's why
we're not terrified because if someone all
of a sudden stood up and branch did knife,
this was not be the same place.
Right?
It was seriously,
if you don't want the same place and you
wouldn't be using the same part of your
brain to process it,
it would switch instantly and you'd be
possessed by ancient motivational states,
terror and rage and and the preparation
for action that would be completely
outside of the neurological systems that
you're using to Orient Yourself at this
movement.
And people do not have to
like it when that happens.
We don't like even if
someone you don't like,
that's like if you're walking down the
street and you see someone who's doing
something that isn't normal,
like maybe they're monitoring
to consultant twitching
a little bit or something
like that and they're a little disheveled.
You'll do what almost everyone does,
which is we'll give them a wide berth
and you'll keep on walking and you
probably do what you can not to make eye
contact because that's an invitation.
So you're,
you're,
you walked down the street and you think,
oh there's some unexplored territory
like circumvented that and maybe
particularly one.
Right?
So you do everything you
can as a consequence of your
actions to stop yourself
from being exposed to anything that
disrupts the stability of the theory that
you're using or hit yourself in the world.
That's why people hold onto their
theories because underneath that it's like
terror,
rage and you don't want that coming up.
And so we don't take it kindly.
People come along and mess with our,
the axioms of our theories.
We seriously don't like that.
And that's partly why people are so
motivated to protect their belief systems,
right?
It's not only then we construe the world,
our belief systems,
we organize our social behavior,
we thought and belief systems.
And so if you mess with
the police systems,
you mess with the structure that makes
everyone predictable of everyone else.
And that is not what I,
there's nothing but hell
would that when that path,
that's for sure.
All right,
so now
we've learned how to act out this pattern
that makes us acceptable and desirable
project and we're constantly
reminding each other how do that,
because like if you go to a party,
you're going to want people,
well who knows what you've been walked by.
If you're the typical person,
a typical,
reasonably well socialized person,
you're going to want people to like,
or that they disliked,
he would.
You're going to want them to pay some
attention to you and you're going to want
to engage people in
interesting conversation.
Maybe you're going to want people to
appreciate you and you know if you want to
have a good time to have a good time
at the party needs to act a certain way
that you're listening to certain separate
responses from other people and if you
fail it that they will tell you,
they'll ignore you.
They won't laugh at your jokes,
you know,
they'll move away from you.
There's,
there's all sorts of reasons.
There's all sorts of things
they will do to broadcast.
At you,
your deviation from the ideal.
And that can be very painful,
right?
Especially if you're very deviant from
the ideal because it opens up this
realization that you just don't know
what the hell are you doing at all.
And that either means that other people
are contemptible and horrible at that
something should be done about that or
that there's something seriously wrong
with you that needs to be rectified.
And neither of those
options are very pleasant.
So we carry within us,
let's say place that ideal
that we carry within us,
a counter ideal as well
be the opposite of that.
That's an introduction in some sense to
the landscape of good and evil because
the ultimate ideal is whatever's good
and the ultimate counter whatevers evil.
So that's the space within which we map
our behaviors and we can't help but map
help that spacing cause it's,
it constitutes the most extreme version
of the structure that we use to evaluate
everything everyone else does.
And every four week.
We also know that that's the case
because when you go to a movie,
even though you don't know that,
you know it's the case,
you go to a movie,
let's say it's an action
or it doesn't matter,
it could be a,
so maybe those are the two
basic categories of votes.
Actually he has a hero.
The hero is either good or partially do
it like a complex here would be good,
but even kind of a flawed
and interesting way.
And then of course in an action movie
there's the evil bad guy as well,
but hopefully he's going to benefit
good interview because otherwise it's a
caricatured always into movies.
You have that the hero and the
villain and the romance welded.
You have the person who's the love
interest in all those who've failed to
measure up.
And so it's just saying,
hey,
it's just played out for
different multiplication reasons.
So,
and you know it's,
it's difficult to understand it
and you go to see your movie,
which is fiction
isn't real.
Then it's also more regal than real
because otherwise you either watch,
you don't want the movie director to
show you how many times to protagonists
links before they get
out a bed in the morning.
It's not interesting when you want them
to do is to take the full panoply of the
heroes behavior and only extract from
those instances that are of particular
interest in relationship to the portrayal
of that ideal or the counter idea.
Do you want to see why the bad guys bad?
And you want to see why
they good guys good.
And that's more real than reality because
it's abstract that from reality it's
more real than reality.
Like numbers are more real than the
things they they're derived from.
It's a form of abstraction,
right?
And it doesn't,
it makes perfect sense that when you
want to extract that from fictional
representations,
just referenced representations
of what's good and what's evil.
So that in principle,
assuming that this is what you want,
you could do a better job of embodying
what's good because then everything would
go well for you in the war room,
assuming that that's what you want.
So there's probably nothing more
important than you could possibly do.
The know do that and
that's how you treat it.
Like it's more important than
anything else you can do.
Because if you think about it,
you will go to a movie and you'll line
up and you hae to be exposed to that kind
of information.
And that's an,
that's an indication of
exactly how vital it is,
right?
You actually find most of you met.
And if it isn't movies,
well then it's,
it's fiction or books of stories
that other people tell you.
Listen,
you have no interest whatsoever in people.
And that's very rare.
If even if that's the case,
you'll find it.
Science fiction or something else like
that where the mythology creeps into the
technology,
it doesn't really matter.
It's going to come at you
in one way or another.
And the fact that we will pay
to expose yourself to that.
And then also that when
you go into those venues,
be entranced by it to spite yourself
despite the fact that you know it isn't
real,
it's an indication of exactly how
important that information is.
Key.
So you could say,
well there's,
there's truth in the extraction of
protections and then the question,
right,
well imagine that you have real life,
have never imagined that you have
first order obstruction fiction,
which are,
look,
if someone's telling you the
story about what they did last,
I mean some people are just going to bore
you too because they're going to tell
you relevant details.
It's like why is it relevant?
What's the difference
between what's relevant,
what is relevant makes you interested,
but why?
Who knows?
You just know when that happens,
you know that the person is
good at telling the story.
So what they're essentially
doing is they're laying
down your experience but not
all of it.
They're selective about,
and that's what makes a born storyteller.
They do first order abstraction again
first order fictionalization in some sense
they say,
here's a bunch of interesting things
that have come in last week and those
interesting things have to have some
bearing on your life in some way or you're
not going to find the interesting,
have a,
you have to know to extract
something of value on there.
Somebody has got a point.
Point is wait,
directs you to some,
so that's what makes you interesting
and then you might think,
well that's just the born storyteller,
but then you had people
who are brilliant at it,
say writing awful circle.
We're producing movies,
street place and they're way better
than a normal person that extracting out
what's important,
like they're geniuses at it and so they
don't just extract out from their life
what's relevant.
Interesting.
They look at a whole bunch of people and
then how to distill that into a single
characters and then they extract out
from them what's relevant and interesting
and they lay out for trailer good
versus evil and transformation.
It's transfixing.
That's what we've been doing with her
religious stories since the beginning of
time.
We'd be watching how we behave.
We've been extracting out the patterns
of that application and we'd be presented
in dramatic form and those stories
are at the bottom of our cognitive
architecture.
That's what are,
it's,
it's within that structure that our
worldviews rests and that is roughly
speaking.
It's the drama of good versus evil on
the landscape of chaos versus order.
Order be that place that you're
familiar with and comfortable with.
The home,
the hearth,
the family,
the country,
the state,
the well organized community,
the gated community,
the walled city,
the places that people have always lived.
And then what's the upside of that?
And that's our reality.
That's the landscape within math.
There's a drama group versus succeed
and that's our fundamental religious
conception of the world.
And you might take,
well you don't believe in that,
but that's not true.
You do believe in that because
if you didn't believe in it,
you wouldn't be human.
To be human is to live in that world.
Now what that means,
metaphysically is very difficult to say.
It has played out.
Support is reality.
Actually.
Chaos versus order with address,
amount of good and evil
being played down in nap.
And that's a very difficult
question to answer,
but one thing I can tell you is that
you act like it is and your brain is
organized like idiots.
And so that's pretty powerful evidence
that there's something going on that's
vaguely related to reality
and not just to imagination.
Okay.
I'm going to tell you if you're a
sequence of very old stories and then I'm
going to tell you about why
don't related to mass murderers,
because I already said that.
If you want to answer that
most difficult question,
you have to go to the deepest possible
level and the deepest possible level
isn't what you know.
You know it's what you act out and maybe
it's what you start to represent it,
but you don't know what it is yet.
It's too profound.
Needs to be visible in
some sense to be partner,
fully articulate knowledge.
One of the things that,
see,
one of the things that
cardio was attempted to do,
see,
I think he was,
I don't know if he was the greatest
thinker of the 20th century,
but he certainly,
he was certainly up there and I'll tell
you what he was up when he took Freud's
idea that you could look at
fantasy and extract out new.
Nolan took that idea seriously.
And then he thought,
well,
dreams that people have in the fantasies
they have are like the mythologies that
they use in their culture.
So the dream is to the individual,
like the myth is to the culture and you
believe that we existed within Stuart's.
If we've been,
I'd describe it.
And I think the evidence
for that by the way,
is incontrovertibly Kenny,
serious psychologist who knows anything
about how the brain functions in any
deep sense is destiny.
Admit that the manner in
which we construct the world
looks like a narrative.
Now had not everyone who raised me,
the psychologist that I've come across.
So I think are the deepest of thinkers
have have drawn that conclusion.
And why did disparate fields,
right?
Ranging from artificial intelligence
to the analysis of dreams.
It's something that's emerged cross this.
So here's where it was
up to the first page.
Pause it.
That was what I just told you about.
It's an extension of Freud's
vision of treatments.
The second idea was that park,
the way they think about the world,
is it banding stories?
Third idea was that these stories were
deeply reflective of who we are and I'm
only culturally,
but in the deepest
possible biological sense.
It wasn't merely armature socio-cultural
structure and I also think the evidence
for that is overwhelming
and crystal court.
First of all,
our fundamental biology is very much
like that of the fundamental biology of
animals,
mammals,
social mammals,
the drugs that work on us,
the site of the drugs that
work psychologically a to
have very similar effects
on animals like rats for example.
We share biological history with that
and to think about us as some divorced
from our biological fundamental is
illusory.
You know that,
you know that might what you don't have
to be talking about when you talk to
someone,
you don't have to talk
about what anger is.
You don't have to talk about what fear is.
You don't have to talk about with jealousy
is you don't have to talk about what
Hungary's.
You might describe your particular hunger,
but you don't have to make a
case for the existence of hunger,
right?
There's all these fundamental human
experiences that are part and parcel of
being embodied.
In the manner that one boy
that are beyond discussion,
it's so self evident like
pain is one you don't,
you don't have to convince someone
else of the existence of pain or the
suffering.
I think this particularly alcohol
in that regard and so we have those
fundamental ways of orienting ourselves
to the world that are deeply rooted
biologically make manifest themselves
in our stories and that makes up part of
our nature and we have to figure out
how to cope with those fundamental
realities of life and the way we do that
just by learning to act in particular
ways in the world are there.
You can strange ways,
which I'll just go sit at the moment.
I just made the case that we live in a
metaphysical store and then in fact the
kind of reality now what seems to have
happened to us that over the last 500
years or something like that,
we invented a new way
of looking at the world.
That's a materialistic view site and
that is exactly the view of story.
It's different than that.
It's a new technology and the problem
seems to be that the emergence of that
which has made us wealthy and to
take the Lord's will be powerful,
doesn't seem to fundamental way
meditative subarc basic story.
Neat.
You have this idea in the league 19
hundreds and hundreds that the conflict
between the scientific world view and
the religious worldview had decimated.
They just will do it.
Can you describe that as the definite
goal and he believed that because of that
had happened,
we had lost our moorings for ethical
mornings and that our society is going to
lost lake.
Very bad men between nihilism
and totalitarianism as a console.
Okay,
neat.
You died quite young believe that in
order to recover from that and find our
bearings again,
that we going to have to replace
the gods that we once believed in.
Let's say,
are you caught up and wants to plead it
with some notion of our own divinity?
Take responsibility for
creating our own doubters?
That was his idea of the superman.
The Overman Yeoman was very interested in.
He just stopped coming because he knew
that we lived inside stories and the
stories had certain actions of value
and then our faith and our fundamental
story had been shaken,
not least by our scientific,
the rising of the scientific knowledge,
and he was interested in trying to figure
out how people might find themselves
reoriented so they
didn't turn to nihilism,
let's say,
or two to tell interi utopian world news,
but put themselves back in the story.
But he didn't buy the niches prognosis
for cure because yoga was influenced by
Freud and Freud and pointed out that
people didn't create their own values.
You can't do that because you have nature
and the nature manifests itself within
you regardless of your choice.
There's things that you can't get
yourself to do and you know that,
right?
Because there's a matter of
creating your own values.
You just think,
well,
you would wake up one morning and you
could just tell yourself what to do.
Like go to the gym two,
three times a week so that
you know you're in good shape,
stopped eating junk or
quit drinking and bang,
you just kill it because you've
got control over yourself.
And well obviously that's just not the
case and that's because there are all
sorts of things operating inside of you
that have their own autonomy and their
own nature that you've Lenny
will have to contend with.
And so that's why you went
back inside the human psyche,
so to speak,
to look at the fantasies that
we spontaneously generated
as a Greek myths of the
world,
to see if he could find out
what the pattern constituted.
Alright,
now I'm going to tell
you this little story.
So this is the idea is
that this is partly,
these stories are partly derived from
thousands or even Ken out tens of
thousands of years of watching how people
act to successfully and unsuccessfully
in the world and extracting overpass.
So you know,
and has the patterns get extracted,
they get more abstract and they get,
I think it less real in some sense
that they get more broadly applicable.
So let me tell you first story.
So this is from the opening chapter,
opening parts of Genesis.
So there's an idea in genesis.
This is roughly how the idea is laid out
and it's an idea that's expressed it.
It tells you all over the
world in different forms.
And so the first time he hit me is
that there's sorts of domains or fee.
There's potential chaos and
there's order having a more,
okay,
now that's,
that's the,
that's the structure of reality.
It's like the Dow was given Yay.
It's the same thing that you're
hemispheres are mapping order and chaos.
And that's what the world's made of.
Okay.
There's a third founder and the third
factor is the thing he mediated between
those two.
And that would be,
that's what people mean when they talk
about consciousness is that seems to be
what consciousness does.
Consciousness establishes order,
your conscious,
you make decisions,
you make it a world.
But while you're being
conscious and attempted,
you're attending to what you don't
yet understand and haven't her.
And so you're faced with some known
and potential and you transform that
effortfully and carefully is what you
understand what you couldn't have that.
So that's what your consciousness does.
And the Genesis,
you see that portrayed,
you see that portrayed as something
that's defined as a divine spirit.
So that's basically Jajuan yellows,
y'all was,
what would you call it,
the process by which you all,
what generates the world
has been terminated.
This is the Christianization of that
story is the term the logos and the logos
is the capacity for attentive,
communicative,
truthful speech.
And so there's a deep idea at
the beginning of genesis step,
whatever divine consciousness is that
which uses trinkled communicated speech to
encounter the chaos of the unknown
and to transform it to happen board.
And so that's a technical description
of the structure of reality.
And it's an ethical injunction as well.
Because what happens in the will in
chapters of genesis is that God uses the
logos to create the world
out of that preexisted chaos.
And He,
and when he does that in stages,
he pronounces it good.
And so there's an idea there are deep it.
It's true.
You need idea because one of the
things you might ask yourself,
and this is one of the things that the
mass murderers asking themselves all the
time,
is being justifiable or is it something
against which you should strive and to
destroy?
And that's a very good
question because life is very,
very difficult and it's full of suffering
and it's full of betrayal and it's
full of malevolence and it's
not an unreasonable proposition.
He question whether it would be better
if you're not thinking at all sisters and
the people who take the steps to doing
the terrible things that they ended up
doing.
Answer that question in the affirmative,
they believe that life
itself is so unbearable.
It was fucking mental structure
that normally should not exist,
but at the right response to it is to
take revenge against the fact that its
existence.
And that's part of the answer to
how you get to where you have to go.
If you're going to rent a van and
drive it for camp blocks on a city,
on city sidewalks,
it's a deep,
deep problem and it's justifiable.
But the hypothesis it's
laid out in genesis,
which is an amazing hypothesis,
is that despite the fragility of the
world and the vulnerability of the world
and it's a proclivity,
let's say towards malevolence,
if you encountered with consciousness
encounters with the potential that the
world is extracted from
Eddie does that truthfully,
then what is created as a consequence
is good and I would say that's the host.
That's the most fundamental act of
faith and I think that's the fundamental
ethical question that lies,
that underlies the entire Corpus of the
stories of what which our culture and
all phones predicate question is,
are you really to act out the proposition
that he is good if you abide by the
truth and what's interesting is
that it's an existential question,
Nate.
It's not a question that you can that can
be answered by fact because no one can
prove it to you because they can't,
they can't tell you what your life is
going to be like if you do that because
you could.
You're the only person that can find out.
And the only way you can find out
essentially by risking everything you can
decide,
well,
I'm going to separate proposition.
That truthful being is that being that
producers what's good and then I'm going
to abide by that,
but then strange things will happen to
you because it isn't necessarily the case
that if you attempt to
abide by your own truth,
that everything that happens to every
second is going to be demonstrative proof
that that's the right pathway.
You'd beat yourself in all sorts of
trouble if you knew that you know that
perfectly well because
there's uncomfortable
conversations that you should
probably have a few people and if you
have those uncomfortable conversations,
it's not like there's big,
it's just going to be
roses and sunshine rather.
You're happy.
The discussion,
quite the contrary.
The truth is a very disruptive force,
especially people that are
living inside an illusion.
And so it is is,
it's a statement.
It's an if it's a metaphysical
statement of faith.
Now this story for aggressive,
so godleys of the world,
but it's not the material world is the
world that I just described as the world
of chaos and order and good and evil
and the historic,
just two creation stories in genesis
and they actually come from slightly
different conditions that people who
put the books together and try to,
they were probably from different
tribes and the tribes came together.
They had to integrate the stories because
otherwise the tribes would fight and
the Bible is actually a consequence of
the integration of tribal stories across
thousands of years and they're
not integrated perfectly,
which is why there are conceptual
contradictions in the Bible.
It doesn't,
it doesn't matter because the pattern,
the pattern Rene's constantly across
the conceptual error daughters,
the second creation story,
it's the story of how he is
actually older than the first one,
but it was placed by whoever edited the
Bible second because that was a way of
making a narrative some more coherently.
What happens in the second
story's this go out.
He's already created Cosmo,
let's say no,
he makes the habitable
place for human beings.
And that's a Gardner.
So that's paradise.
It's paradise is a
walled garden or eating,
which needs well watering space.
And so the idea is that the proper
environment for you human ne is a wall
enclosure.
That's well water.
And there's a mythological id
on that because what's a garden?
A garden is nature and culture together.
It proper union,
right?
Because obviously the nature is the plants
and the growth and the culture is the
tending that it takes to make that the
proper place for human beings to live.
So there's chaos.
Order Echo there.
Chaos being nature in order,
big culture,
that's the proper
environment for human beings.
It has to be wall because well,
you have to live with a wool environment,
right?
Your house,
your roots have walls,
your houses have walls,
your cities are pounding,
your states have boundaries.
Your countries have borders.
It's woefully thing.
Bowls with the mold.
And you need that.
Pardon me?
Because there isn't that much of you
and you have to wall over a tremendous
amount of complexity in order to survive.
The gardener who go ahead,
which men and women there
and he says to them,
you can do whatever you want to garden,
but there's a tree in the middle of
the garden and it has the fruit of the
knowledge of good and evil on
an end you're not to touch that.
And so that's a very curious thing.
First curious questioning his
wife and the damn tree again.
And the second day is what the hell's
going expect to be told people not to pass
with that tree.
Because the first thing that would happen
when she told people not to do that is
that's exactly what they would do.
Cause that's exactly what we're like.
So
eve is tempted by the snake
and she eats the apple
that praises other industries.
One of the mysteries is what's up with
the snake and why did you go on with that
with the gardener?
But here's the answer for them.
As far as I can tell,
it's a very complicated answer,
unfortunately is a very complicated topic.
There's no way of walling
know everything ever.
Right?
So let's say do everything you possibly
can to make out a safe and secure
environment for your children.
But what are you going to do
about Internet pornography,
south side?
Are you going to forbid
them to use the internet?
Well,
that's the only way of getting
rid of a whole set of snakes.
But you know what kind of timeline you're
going to have to be in order to manage
that.
What need to do to change
it in the basement?
Well then you've just replaced the
Internet snake with the Tyrese snake.
You have,
you gotten rid of the snake,
he,
there's no getting rid of the snake.
That's the thing about the biblical
story was that if you're going to make a
walled garden,
you're going to put a snake in it
and there's no way around that.
And so,
and that's merely to say that
something unexpected always exist.
So no matter how well
protected the surroundings.
So then the question is,
well what happens when you
interacted with the snake?
What happened
in the story of Adam and eve
when they were first created?
They kind of seem unconscious seven,
you're not really awake and
they interact with the snake,
which is just unexpected thing is some
expected thing that has a touch of
malevolence it and they wake up,
right?
Cause this,
the story says that after the serpent
tells each this particular fruit that
she'll be wise,
like caught and so she eats
her eyes open up the scales,
fall for bribes.
That's a mythological idea that's
associated with the London lightning or
illumination or vision like because to
have the scales fall from your eyes has
to see something that
you haven't seen before.
What do you see?
Right?
Right.
Immediately did cheese.
What does that mean?
Well first of all,
you might notice that you're all close
human needs and be wearing clothes,
clothes for a very long period of time.
It's tens of thousands of years and
actually track the evolution of lice and
clothing.
You can track the evolution of clothing
by tracking the genetic structure of
human lights,
because license all claim to clothing
and you can tell how far back do you hold
that ability until you can derive from
that an indication of when people first
started to wear clothes.
So it's been long enough so
that license invulnerable to,
to,
to the downtown.
So it's a long time.
And why are your clothes,
he wakes up,
then she waits out of the house
and she notices that she's naked.
Okay.
Now think about human beings.
First of all,
we're not down on all fours,
right?
We're
now an animal's,
you're done all for the most
vulnerable parts of them are hidden.
I'm kind of armor light
structures of their bag.
It's not that easy to get at.
An animal is vulnerable parts
and some amicable curl up,
right?
[inaudible] makes it hard
for them to be torn apart.
Not Us.
We're right up,
right?
And the most vulnerable parts
of us are exposed to the world,
to the,
not only to the elements,
to the analysis of everyone else.
So it's not only are our
knowledge of our nakedness,
let's say against the terrible different
nations of nature because we're rather
soft and tender and delicious bio with
hours and but also because we're exposed
to the evaluation of other people and to
wake up and realize that that's a very
interesting thing because it means
that what happened to eat when she was
enlightened in the garden was that
she woke up and realized that she was
vulnerable,
right?
Fundamentally vulnerable.
And then two things happen.
This realization that the dam and
there's a realization of good and evil.
Now the realization of death,
that's relatively easy to
understand because if you
wake up and you realize that
you are vulnerable,
the logical extension of that,
it's to know that you could die,
right?
The logical stands for acknowledge
of vulnerability is to view the future
as a finite place to view yourself as
something that's started a terminal
and and as far as we know will lead.
Human beings have that million.
And so that's something
completely different than
other teachers because we're
aware of our own vulnerability and the
level isn't the case any other creature.
And that biblical story relates that as
a cataclysmic event in the structure of
the world.
And I think that's a reasonable way
of proceeding it because we are,
we aren't conscious creatures and we're
the only creatures that are true self
conscious and we don't know what the
essential significance of that is except
that for us certainly propelled us
into our historical developments.
So at least at the human level,
it's a cataclysmic discovery.
And then the next question is,
well,
okay fine.
So that's why you wake up when you
discovered her naked and that kind of seek
the knowledge and the world.
What about needle?
Well,
I'm puzzled on that for like 15 years.
Starts to take off once
the health of the launch.
Then why does that,
why does the story relate to that way?
And more importantly,
why do we remember that story,
right?
That's an old stories.
Dozens of years old.
It's written for him and God
only knows how old in its world.
We don't forget this story.
Well why not?
Well,
who knows it into our memories come out.
That's why we didn't
forget they talk this week.
So reason for that possibly.
I'm assuming that there's a reason for it.
Well,
I didn't figure it out a little
bit about it and 12 of us for life,
when you know you're vulnerable,
you know a hundred people there
and as soon as you know that your phone
to hold another people are vulnerable,
you understand how you can be hurt,
right?
You don't just hit hurt.
You understand how you could be heard.
And as soon as you understand
how you can be heard,
then you know how long
people can be heard.
And as soon as you know how I met,
Then what you have is the knowledge of
good and evil because then you can decide
whether you're going to use your
knowledge of what hurts you to hurt other
people and you're going to
get the client to do that.
And so part of what
that means is that the,
the whole issue of moral choice
all of a sudden enters the world.
And that's the landscape
happened.
Alright,
so then what happens
if you could wake up,
which I think is right because I think
that women probably Walkman and then we'd
never forgiven you for,
I think that that happens
actually all the time,
which is part of the reason why the man
in my Toronto drove up on the side door,
killed all those people is because women
were making himself and he didn't like
it.
No one,
even him and his self
conscience or something like
I'm constitute in such a way
that what I desire is
rejection and then maybe
bigger low on comprehension and murders.
Now women are prone to reject man.
You have twice as many female
ancestors as male ancestors.
And the evolutionary
biology seems quite clear.
The reason that we've diverged from a
common ancestor of chimpanzees like human
beings is because chimpanzee females
are not sexually selective and human
females are.
And that needs that.
Whatever progress we've made as a species,
assuming what we made constitutes progress
as been as a consequence of women to
proclivity to reject man.
And you might think,
well,
maybe that's a price worth paying,
but it's not necessarily a
price that you want to pay.
If you happen to be one of those band,
you were constantly being rejected.
Now perhaps you the right
attitude to that is,
well you should figure out how to
retool yourself so that you're not being
rejected by 50% of the population,
which is fairly solid evidence that
there might be something about you that's
not exactly like straight
and appropriate let's say.
But you know that's a harsh,
that's the harshest of all
possible judgements and it's
very difficult thing for
people to accept and no one did.
So.
Okay,
so anyways,
evenings having self conscious and then,
then what happens?
Well the next part of this story is a
black comedy and so God goes for a walk to
the garden and he's accustomed
to walking without him.
What that means to me,
I think it's something like we've already
conceptualized in this talk to some
degree with Gog represents at least in
this part of the narrative cycling or it
represents that divine consciousness.
Let's say that you partake in that
confronts the potential of chaos,
transplants,
actuality to walk with that is
to be guided by that principle.
You know,
if you're on the street,
you know path,
you're where you should be at your
life and not sure what you're doing.
And maybe that requires courage.
It requires you to be forthright
and it requires you to look up into,
to try to make the world a better
place rather than a terrible place.
And so Adam's just the customers,
do we have it today after he's
woken up and become self conscious,
he hides like the hook.
And that's partly why it's comical
because you can't hide behind.
You can't hide from God
behind that Bush in a look.
Once somebody's gone is that
I can even see through a bush,
it's like,
and it doesn't reflect for
evolve out to intelligence God.
And he's hiding behind a bush.
And then he comes up with three
ladies skews to so go out calls,
offices,
what's,
what's up,
we're supposed to go for a walk it out.
And he says,
um,
I make an end to shame.
And God says,
who told you that you were naked and
this is the terrible part of the story.
Um,
you know,
because eve is often
portrayed as the villain.
At least that's the theory,
right?
If you,
if you,
if you regard the mythical stories as
part of the patriarchal oppression,
centuries long patriarchal oppression
and eve is the bag first of whose rocket
man time madam is needs some think that
it's complete rubbish because how did he
shows his true colors in the
second part of the story?
Because as soon as God calls him
who said that you were naked,
what does he do?
He says he does two things.
He said,
remember that the woman who made for me,
it's her fault.
And so that's a perfect day because it
doesn't take responsibility for his own
action.
And first he blames the woman
and then you'd late God.
Right.
And you might think that takes a fair
bit of goal and that's exactly right.
I mean this is relevant.
It's relevant because that's exactly
what happened to this man in Toronto who
killed all those people.
First thing you did because of his
painful self consciousness as plain white
men.
And the second thing
you did was blaming God.
And the third one he did
was take his revenge.
Okay,
so that's the next story.
So God isn't very happy with this because
now the structure of Ba is permanently
disrupted by the emergence
of self consciousness and
the knowledge of death and
the emergence of the
knowledge of good and evil.
It's like so much for that paradise,
right?
It's people have evolved
beyond their childhood.
Harriet's same thing happens
to the Buddha when he matures,
right?
Because as father and
links in a walled city,
it's all where there's no
age and there's no death,
there's no sickness.
And he grows up in there
and everything's perfect,
but it gets curious.
He goes outside the walls of the city
and the first thing he encounters is
sickness.
And then he encounters old age at
different voyage and any encounters,
death and he encounters get
never goes back inside the waltz,
in his father's name for it.
It's exactly the same.
Might be.
So anyways,
God says,
well now to change up,
you know,
you've really done it.
Here's what's going to happen.
You knew about the future and
now you're going to have to work.
Because as soon as you
know about the future,
then you have to work.
Because even if things are going well
now that doesn't mean they're going to go
well in Amman and you
better get ready for that.
You better get ready for the winter then
get ready for your old age and they're
getting ready for the fact that you
might get ill and so you're work.
That's that.
As human beings work,
we work because we're aware of the
future and he tells eve while you're in
trouble too,
and I won't go into
this in too much detail,
but part of each trouble is that she's
going to give birth to intelligent,
large skull and highly dependent children
and they're going to tear her apart
and shelter and she's going to have
to be dependent on her husband.
And so those are the dual curses
of whatever we get into wake up.
So when the world and what my history
starts as far as the biblical stories are
concerned.
And then there's the second story
is the story of painting
and very short stories.
Something about a paragraph long,
it's like 10 seconds.
It's got to meet that richest
10 sentence has ever written.
And I think so he had looked
at first two real big,
I need not because either leave by
out so he can hardly count them.
Now Cain and Abel were actually born
in history to a mother and a father.
So then there was the
real no real human beings,
right?
In the real world.
And there are a pattern.
There's a pattern of a hostile progress
like foreign local evangelicals,
right?
Or Harry Potter and Voldemort.
Same IPFS is,
or back after the Joburg or superman and
Lex Luthor doesn't matter the good guy
and a bad guy,
right?
The or that,
the quasi messiah and the safety himself,
right?
It's the same pattern,
intention and tested instantly as
soon as this landscape is laid out.
So what happens to Cain and Abel?
Well,
they made sacrifices and that's the
first part of the story that hard to
understand.
His April offers the best pumps of neat
that he has is the choices everyone's
from Splore burdensome
offers the smoke you got,
it's a little lonely aren't caring side.
Right.
So what's the idea?
Well God is in the heavens.
What you think that I'll get,
cause when you look up at the night sky,
it fills you with awe.
You can seize this infinite expanse.
You have to say the spirits.
When you look at the sun and the moon,
it's that which is beyond you.
The human imagination
populates that domain,
which divinity?
The ultimate well and where is that?
It's out.
Well how do you communicate with what's,
oh smoke rises and so you offer something
to the absolute and it can get a sense
of the quality of your offering as a
consequence of the rising of the smoke.
Like I said,
it's an archaic idea that you can grow
it as this childlike idea of not child
Yasha a child life.
So you communicate with
dogs from sacrifice.
Cain sacrifices his offerings
and able sacrifices his,
but then because we're taking
these stories seriously,
okay,
well what's going on?
For example,
well here's what's going on and this
is how finding the 12 rules for life as
well.
This is also about 20 years to figure out
what about this idea of separate twice
what the health behind that,
because it's a human universal,
right?
You find sacrificial,
OTC efferent.
We remember while you can think,
you can think it through,
if you think about how people
use the word sacrifice in,
in,
in really modern times.
Or I teach my students at
the University of trial,
but other than when children
are first generation immigrants,
so they're,
you know,
their parents sacrificed a lot in
order to give them an opportunity.
So what they sacrifice,
but they offer the sacrifice
of their home country.
Sometimes they sacrifice a profession
because maybe they were doctors where they
came,
the couldn't get licensed in Canada,
so they end up running up convenience
store or laundry or something like that.
Working,
you know,
punishing their kids have an opportunity.
So if you ask the kids,
but what did your parents sacrificing
that you could go to university?
It's like their hands are up right away.
They have the staff that language
and then you can ask them to,
well,
what do you sacrifice for your
grades all I don't party every night,
right?
I for go ratification.
So what does it mean?
I sacrifice something I valued APG
make to make the future better.
I'm acting out the proposition that I
can bargain with Phage by giving them
something.
Now I can make something
better in the future.
That is an absolutely
overwhelming discovery.
That's what human beings discovered is
that it's so strange because it works.
You can give up things that you value in
the present and it does pay off in the
future.
Now that's partly because you're
bargaining with future people,
but I'm not going to get into that.
You can read more about how the
12 rules for life if you warm.
The point is that it wasn't archaic as
the ritual was Sikh people were acting up
something they didn't understand.
They've watched how people
that were successful were
successful and they watched
people how people who weren't successful
weren't successful and they extracted
out this idea that the people who were
successful were doing something that made
them successful and it was like sacrifice.
And so they ritualizing sacrifices
have you understand what it was and
eventually that became
a psychological concept,
which was,
well,
you can give,
you know,
you do that when you to renew
yourself and the new year's festival,
by the way,
which is an unbelievably old idea.
You give up your pathological
past self and you make some,
what do you call,
goals,
resolution.
There's some issues about how you can
be a very new in the future and that's a
sacrificial app and it's based on
a very old ritual that has roots,
at least in Mesopotamia,
at least 5,000 years ago
where the king had to,
I'd do that every new year so that he
could be a good king for the upcoming
year,
which you can also read about that.
It maps it.
Maybe you want to read about that.
The interesting anyways.
The whole idea is that
this whole sacrifice,
this actually works,
and then that rig that brings
up a whole realm of questions.
It's like,
well,
the sacrifice works.
What's the best possible sacrifice,
right?
Because that's obviously when
you figured out that it works,
you want to figure out what we optimize
it and part of that is you have to
sacrifice that which she loved and
that's part of the active labor.
When Abraham is called on to sacrifice,
I say,
I guess the emergence of that idea,
maybe what you love most is a
personally love the most and you think,
well does that mean you said
offer your son up to God?
Hence what you mean when you ask me
the questions because the answer that
question is actually yes.
In fact,
that's exactly what you do if you're an
ideal parent because you want your son
and your daughter to be as good as
they can possibly be,
let's say.
How can make any sacrifices that
are necessary in order to carry,
there's your life.
So even though the idea again
is barbaric and are archaic,
couldn't it's ritual form.
There's a siege in that are calculable.
Brilliant.
In any case,
God's happy with Abel sacrifices and he's
not happy with Katie suffer pharmacies
and there's reality and is not
exactly what the swine and the story,
it's kind of thing.
Not Exactly.
There's hymns,
but it's vague and that's
good because you know,
you know what life is like if you're
doing everything you can to sick yourself,
right?
And to put the world in order
around and it isn't working,
your sacrifices are being rejected.
Well,
what's the consequence of that?
if you're not trying,
when you fail,
well that's sucks because it's not very
exciting not to try and who the hell
wants to fail,
but at least you're not
punished for your best efforts.
But if you make your sacrifices
and they're rejected,
then what's the right attitude towards up?
Well,
Keynes out.
The key is to get bigger.
He gets fitter because Abel is,
you're making these
sacrifices and works like mad.
God's thrilled about Abel.
He's partner with a women blocks increase.
Everybody likes him worse.
He's the sort of guy who deserves
it and that's super annoying,
right?
Because there's nothing more annoying
than coming to meet someone hyper
successful and then also
realizing that they deserve it.
You think that person would have the
good graces to be contemptible so you
wouldn't have to be envious about the
fact that everything is going well for
them.
But often that doesn't work out.
So Kane isn't he raised by Dick Spice,
continual failure and he's outraged at
Abel because Abel successes casting this
failure and even a more dim light
and he's brooding about the unjustice
injustice in the world and so he decides
to call out God because Adam get it,
why not cane?
And so he has a little chat with God
and says something along the lines.
I've heard a lot of different translations
of this major change to get to what
was at the bottom of it
is quite complicated.
But basically what happens
is Katie calls out God,
creator of reality.
He says something like,
what the hell is up here?
I'm breaking myself in half trying
to have a half decent life in.
Everything I do is turns to ash.
And then there's my brother whose doesn't
seem to be making sacrifices or any
more heartfelt than me,
isn't spectacular success.
It's like,
what the Hell's going on?
Kinda crazy planet.
Is this anyway to that you've created
where this sort of thing is so likely to
happen?
How do you know you might
first of all go to that?
The probability that you thought that
way of you license from time to time is
100% in fact,
I suspect that there's a substantial
number of you in the room who think like
that almost all the time.
It's extraordinary attempting because
when things fall apart for you,
which they do from time to time,
it's like,
well,
who doesn't want to go outside and shake
his fist at the sky and rail against
the horror of blind faith?
Right?
The question arises,
how can the world be constituted in such
an unjust manner and who's to blame?
You might say,
well,
I don't believe in God.
It's again,
it's irrelevant.
It doesn't matter from the psychological
perspective it happens anyways.
You act it out anyways.
Also,
God listens,
but he's not,
you know,
taking responsibility because,
because he thinks it's king's fault.
And so this is what he
tells kink essentially.
He says it's a very
interesting use of language.
He says,
Sin crouches sin by the way,
that we're needs to draw your
Arrow back and to miss the target.
It's a very particular kind of work.
It needs to miss what you're in
rehab or perhaps in a team at all.
So it implies that perhaps you're aiming
wrong if you don't hit the target right
and you specify the target.
So that's an interesting part
of that as well says to Cain,
Sin Crouches at your door like
a predatory sexually aroused cap
you've invited into your life.
You've opened the door to it and you
voluntarily had your way with it.
And it means that in a sexual manner,
it's sort of like the old idea that a
vampire can't come into your house on us.
He would fight it.
So first of all,
he tells Kane,
don't be so sure that it's the structure
of reality that's at fault here.
Maybe it's something that you're
either doing or not doing.
And he accuses him directly.
He says,
not only are you not giving it,
you're also doing it.
There's something there that's lurking.
It's not good.
You've asked him to come in,
no way have you asked him to command.
You made it with it in a creative manner
and you've given birth to something
horrible as a consequence and you know it.
And so that's what happens
when you mess with God.
You find out things that
you don't want to find out.
And so painting was not very happy
when he started this discussion.
And when he's done with the discussion,
he's seriously not happy.
And the story says his countenance fell,
which means that he was
enraged by that answer.
And no wonder because he's got
the problem that he had before,
which is that everything's
going to hell around him.
And his brother was
thriving plus go on himself,
just told him that it's completely his
fault and that he knows he's doing it and
then he chose to do it.
Well,
what's,
what are you going to do
in a situation like that?
Well,
you do what people do.
You take a rock and you
killed your brother.
Right?
And that's what happens.
And that's it.
It's a horrifying story because
it's really the first story.
And it's a story of Andy and
hatred and murder and worse,
because what happens then is Katie is
spared by God for complex reasons that we
won't get into them.
And then he goes out and has a family
and he has his descendants and one of his
descendants as Tubal Cade and bulky and
use the first person who makes weapons
of war.
So there's this idea that the corruption
of the individual that rips represented
by Kane is part of the process.
That,
so there's more to that.
So if you,
if you,
it's so pain,
let's say kills you.
If you insult child and [inaudible]
seven and if you insult Keynes,
grandchild,
then he kills 49 to two.
So there's this idea that
this corrupt process,
that king part Tolkien
expands exponentially,
I'll give to the community came judicial
descendant is to Boucane who makes
weapons of war.
Yeah.
Right?
So does this direct line in the story
between the Pauling vengeful nature of
cane and his jealousy and spite and
refusal to take responsibility for the
consequences of his actions and
inactions murder and genocide.
And it's all in like one paragraph.
It's absolutely overwhelming.
And the next story is the flood.
So
back to the high school shoes,
they're just acting out
exactly the same old story.
It's the same thing over and over.
And that's why these stories are typical.
It's why we can never forget them.
They always happen and hope we need to
come to understand that I'm just going to
have some possibility of avoiding
the worst of the catastrophes.
High school shooters,
people like to call them my kids.
They wrote down what they did.
No,
as far as they were concerned,
they would reject it,
at least in part.
You know,
people make much of that saying,
well the poor kids who were bullied
and that's why they do prevent,
just like first of all the
morning stuff and kids.
Second of all,
most people are voting and they
don't want to blow up to high school.
And it wasn't just that they call them.
My kids wanted to go in there and kill.
That was only a tiny fraction of what
they were planning in their fantasies.
They wanted to take out the whole city,
the entire city.
They have propane bones plans that
they wanted to make a media spectacle.
It management quick attracted.
They want to produce as much mayhem
as they possibly could in the shortest
possible period of time and cap
it off with their own suicide.
Just to demonstrate how little they
character the damn world and that's the
motivation behind that sort of thing.
It's a deep and dark motivation.
One of the things that's been helpful
to me in studying all of this,
here's an idea.
Here's an idea that's expressed,
Christian symbolism.
There was an idea that Christ was
crucified before he was taken to heaven,
had to go to hell.
That heroin hell let him rise.
It's a mythological idea.
It's not canonical biblical
idea as far as I'm aware,
but there's an idea there.
If you want to move up,
you have to go down first
and you kind of know this,
right?
Because most of the things that
you've learned in your life,
you've learned the hard way and so most
any culpable increased in wisdom tends
to come at a sacrificial costs.
It will,
you has to die and there's an intermediary
period of chaos and horror and then
maybe come out of that your
why is it more work together,
what you paid for it.
And so
one of the things that's
being the consequence of
that process for me is that,
you know,
I've looked into these,
this motivation for an atrocity
and I told you what I've included,
you could make about what you want,
but it's also done something
very positive for me,
which is to shed light on something else,
which is,
well let's say you can declare this has
to do with the solution of the problem,
but say you can detail about the problem
and so I need to help out the problem.
If it's,
if it's detailed out property,
then there's a solution
that emerges from it.
If you could identify the
nature of true malevolence,
then you clarify the
nature of its opposite,
which is whatever is good.
And then you can perhaps pursue that.
Perhaps that's how you can straight
the malevolence whatever good is,
is not what he had.
It's the opposite of that.
And some would say,
well,
what do you do
instead of trending,
trending down the path of change.
And that's that is
you don't look for the insufficiency of
the world in the structure of the world.
You look for the insufficiency of
the structure of the world in you.
If things aren't going
well enough for you,
then you have some work to
do and you might pay well.
That's a hell of a thing
happen because the world,
there's a lot to it and it's
a rain against you in some
many ways and there's no
doubt that that's the case.
You've got your options.
You can either pass your catastrophe at
the feet of God and become bitter and
cruel and resentful and worse as a
constant lines or you can take it upon
yourself to improve what you improve
and also assume that the same time that
there's enough to you that you can
actually bench and CSA which regards to
malevolence itself.
You can look for that upside of yourself
and there's evidence for it outside of
yourself,
and then you can go after those
people that you regard as particularly
malevolent and straighten
the world up that way.
But that's how insurance develop.
No,
and there's a better idea,
which is you might want to
look to yourself first and
see just how much of that
you can constraint inside yourself.
Start before you start worrying about how
much of that younger the constraint it
under people.
And so that's why you need to send
your house in perfect order before he
criticized the world.
Because all of that sounded to me that
unless you want things to go down the
pathway,
the cane I would go on and the
people still go down constantly.
There might making
everything worse for them,
for their families,
for the community,
for the world.
You have the alternative of
taking all of that onto yourself,
right?
And so that's fine.
In our most profound
transformative stories,
let's say the person who revives me
the world is the person who voluntarily
accepts their own vulnerability.
That's what's symbolized
by the crucifixion.
That's why that symbol as
Gregory Poole for 2000 years,
since the proper pathway is to take on
your mortality as your responsibility.
And the second is to
seven.
How would I put this
to notice that the temptation that's laid
out by the spirit of malevolence is it
temptation that you confront that you
have to take responsibility for it and
then you have to attain victory over?
It's a psychological drama and that's
the story that sits as the boy and what
her culture with its emphasis on the
divinity of the individual isn't the
suffering of the individual.
It's divine.
It's not the malevolence
of the individual,
it's divine.
It's the capacity of the individual in
principle to accept both of those into,
to work for the remediation.
And that's the story that allows
us our natural rights and our,
and the responsibility that we have
taught ourselves into our families,
into the community.
And it's the acting out of that story
that produces individuals who are helping
them thrive.
Families that work and surviving in
communities that are integral and don't
degenerate into something
resembling health.
And it's important as Carl,
you don't point it out for us to wake
up because we're so powerful now we need
to wake up and we need to understand
what it is that we'd be doing right and
wrong for all of this time
and to implement that as
consciously and clearheaded
Layton intentively properly as we
possibly can individualize and to see what
great things might happen.
How's it going?
Some points if you did so
[inaudible]
it's so
hard from the stage for a
couple of minutes and they're
going to set it up again
in a slightly different format and then
I'm going to come out with my laptop and
you've all provided.
Many of you have provided the questions.
We're going to spend half an hour with
the questions and the answers that will
bring the evening to a close.
Thank you.
[inaudible]
wonderful.
Standing on
your shoulders back
a little bit for some of the questions
that you guys had already submitted.
The
sewer is amazing,
just it's incredible.
It's exceeded all our expectations.
This is now the fifth show.
Uh,
currently scheduled 40 shows us
also going to London next week.
We are adding shows all the time.
Uh,
they've been adding cities
or returning to this.
He said they sent a sold very well.
We sold out all by shows
and every night is,
his presentation has been different.
It's been a different subject matter.
So if you want to return to some shows
in the future that they're going to be
very different.
He is so inclusive.
It doesn't cross the aisles.
It crosses oceans.
We had people here from Russia
and community shows already.
Just the first slide.
China,
Japan,
uh,
of course Canada.
How many,
many Canadians here tonight.
Uh,
it,
I really do like it and we're
just seeing the beginning of a,
the positive nature of it and
the healthy and I'm sure a a lot.
You'd be home.
We'll continue to bring in a lot of other
people in the states around the world.
It's just amazing,
except the book trade is
going to translate as well.
Uh,
someone was in our minds,
seven countries in the Arabic,
so it will be everywhere.
Uh,
various,
uh,
okay.
Uh,
what he's made to sit down and
you're ready to start with the Q and.
A and again,
please welcome back to the
stage Dr. Jordan Peterson.
[inaudible].
All right,
so
how long a person go about finding
your calling purpose or passion?
Well,
are you going to say bagging?
Um,
because what the hell do you know?
I agree being a technical as well.
So I have this program called
the cell phones program.
Its components is the future authoring
programs and it asks people to consider
their lives deeply and to
develop a vision and a strategy.
And it's not an easy,
did have someone who
hasn't been encouraged,
let's say self position because
they're non practice data.
People say,
well I don't know what I should be doing.
It's like,
well,
you know,
some things she shouldn't be doing.
So that's a good start.
And I don't mean that in
the most practical manner.
If you don't know what to do,
you could start by stopping doing all
the stupid things that you're doing that
you know are stupid.
And that's a good start because
it starts to clear your vision.
So if you,
if you don't know what to do,
but I do know that you're doing things
that you're ashamed of and that you
regret.
You could start by just eliminating
employed by one and slowly given it to the
best of your ability.
And then as you're,
and so that's really a vendor is starting
to become disciplined to false of
ethical rules,
some,
some set of ethical rules with any logic
to follow a set of ethical rules long
enough,
then you'll get disciplined enough.
So you'll start to have a clearer vision
and then you might be able to see the
way forward for you might see a way
forward port for intensity rather than
merely what you should avoid.
So that's a good initial practical issue.
It's about,
because everyone knows you know perfectly
well that there are things you're
doing that you know you shouldn't do it,
but you don't stop,
start stopping
because part of this idea about putting
your house in perfect order before you
criticize the world,
because there's a question,
it's always open.
And as far as,
this is the question,
so to speak,
that God placed in front of cake.
It's like,
well,
how do you know the world would be a
terrific place if he weren't such a
wretched thing?
Maybe it wouldn't be.
He might say,
well,
that's a pretty casual answer.
Would you say to people who has a parent
who's dying with Alzheimer's disease
for example?
It's like whether you can get their act
together and he's going to fix that,
looks like it would make it a hell
of a lot better than it wouldn't be
otherwise.
I can tell you that.
And that's something because it's bad
enough to have someone who's dead deal and
your family without having an incredibly
amount of unnecessary pathology
gathered around that and make something
that could be merely tragic into
something that's outright hell.
And that happens to people all the time.
And so even if it's
not a perfect solution,
is the best solution that you have.
And then the next part of that is when
I suggest to people that they do the
future authoring program and they're,
they're leery about doing it.
I asked them to do it bad because a
bad plan is waving the didn't know plan
because if you implemented that plan
then you learn why ain't you that plan.
Exactly.
Not Hypothetically but exactly in
New Orleans and then in and use that
information above her failure
to retool the better acquire.
And so the English men pageant,
you're,
you're tracking the destination,
it's moving,
there's some kind of ideal
in your vision is blurry,
they don't know where to look so you're
going to go this way and then you can go
that way.
We can go this way.
But if you keep doing that then the
deviations from the right path agreed to
decrease with time and eventually you'll
be walking forward in an efficient
manner and you might have to get all
sorts of errors before you manage that.
But I watched people long enough in my
clinical practice to know that waiting
for Godot and a very bad idea and
non growing up as a very bad idea.
It's like implement the
best plan that has to happen
and learn from and that works and you
get sharper at making your planets.
And then the other thing that we do in
the future of your program does what we
ask people,
well maybe you can't decide what your
passion or your calling should be.
That's a pretty global question.
But you might ask yourself
some questions like,
well is there something you could do
to improve your intimate relationship?
One thing,
is there a way that you can
improve your friendships?
Is there something you can do at your
job that would make it better than it is
now?
Even if it's something incremental,
could you do something more productive
and meaningful with your time outside of,
could you be
slightly better at handling
temptations that come your way?
Could you take care of herself somewhat?
You better be mentally and physically.
But you know the answers to all
of those questions is Jeffery.
Yeah.
So then you can even ask
themselves a simpler question,
which would be,
well,
if there is something that you could do
that would make one post things better,
is there also something they wouldn't do?
And then you can ask yourself that,
you know,
instead of telling
yourself that you should,
which is the same thing,
might say,
well I would like my marriage
because you said you ask yourself,
well how can my marriage be better?
And you'll get a bunch of answers and
most of you will like because if you
really ask yourself a question like that,
the part of our brain,
this is management doesn't,
it's looking for new answers,
will tell you.
And then we'll tell you a bunch of
things you don't want to hear and Lord of
them won't be things you already know.
And some of what we think speakers
just no damn way you we get to know,
you know that you should.
But some,
some said that those might be things that
you should do that by your definition
that you actually would do.
It might be trivial or books or guilt,
but at least a step in the right direction
so he would never step in the right
direction.
You're willing to take day by day
and that's incremental progress.
It'll spiral.
It goes firewall,
and there's a stake in the New Testament,
which actually happens
to be true statement,
which is to those who have everything
more will be given and it's a,
it's a reflection of his
underlying phenomenon.
Phenomenon.
It looks like the natural law schools,
it's as things start to recruit to you,
the rate at which they need further,
the crew will increase.
That's a natural law school price.
As long as sometimes great opens,
it reflect or just confusion.
So there's a chapter promos for polite,
calm down.
Don't compare yourself.
Compare yourself and
who you were yesterday,
not someone else's today.
And it's a new junction for
incremental improvement.
If you don't know where to go,
when you like,
think about where you are and
see if today you could make,
where do you want somewhat better when
something is so that when you go to bed
at night,
you're not asking Richard as you
were when you woke up in the morning.
And so if you do that for two years,
you know what do you make
it a just a small thing,
something you could actually
do that you wouldn't do,
then your life will be waiting here and
at the end of that you might have enough
clarity of mind to start to understand
where you would go if things worked out
for you across the world.
So that's the answer.
Okay.
How do we encourage others to fix
themselves as they reduce personal
responsibility or blame idiot lords with
Ruth the system for all their trouble
by example.
That's the best way to do it.
You know there's another
new of injunction,
rather harsh
don't cows.
Pearls will force one and took me a
long time to understand that because he
really is a harsh statement.
But here's the,
here's the gist of it.
If you're talking to someone
and they're not distinct,
you should shut up.
It's really hard thing to
learn because you think,
man,
I just keep telling this person,
they'll listen if I no they won't.
They're shelf will just get harder.
And so here's what's happening.
If you're talking to someone
and they're not listening,
you are not receiving thinks you are.
That's why they're not listening.
You're actually wrong
in a local situation.
Now they might also be wrong,
but what are you going to do about that?
But you could show me wrong.
And so if you try a couple of times,
say you were telling me some things to
a family member for their own good and
maybe you actually are and maybe it's
for their own good and maybe they should
listen and maybe you're right
and all of those things,
but they're not busy and he told him like
six times or nothing's out put telling
me it isn't working.
The problem isn't the
problem you think it is.
That's why your approach is working.
And so one of the things you could
do with a situation like that,
it's quick,
just quit doing it.
And I would say pull back
from the person and watch.
Don't offer them anything.
Don't tell them your wisdom,
give them any advice,
tell him anything about yourself.
Just watch and listen.
If you do that for like a year,
they will tell you what's
wrong with them and case.
But that will only happen if you
prick casting pearls before swine.
And then you say,
well,
let's say you have someone in your
family just absolutely intractable,
they're just not changing and nothing
you can do is going to fix that.
And that's unbelievably common.
So like what can you do?
Well maybe not because people have a
guesstimate and there's might be that and
you might not be the person who
could do anything about that.
And so you don't want to destroy yourself.
You know how you approach
someone who's drumming,
the panicking,
you approach the lift your foot up,
swimming this way towards
and you do that because,
and you tell them you have
to stop panicking or I'm up.
Or the risk of VTE.
And the reason is because drunk
people is not better than one.
And you don't have to
tell them that recently.
But you could
if there's someone that you did with is
attracted or sacrificing yourself and
also being part of that
attracted the problem.
It's not helpful.
So you do what you can and you live by
example and maybe if the person has any
chance they watch you and maybe they
have to watch it for 10 years and they
learn or they fail to learn,
in which case you've done it again.
And that's how it is.
So he's his function.
It's sound
[inaudible]
on the 17 year old girl.
Well maybe it is,
but I don't think it is.
So you know,
there's this idea that the only
people who are listening to me or,
hey Barry white men
[inaudible]
as far as I'm concerned,
and this is just so observes the,
I can't believe that this is easy to
become controversial and talking to people
about taking responsibility for the state
of the world onto themselves and the
radical leftist identity.
All it politics.
Any alarms can only do this through the
lens of the radical left has an identity
politics instead of noticing that this
isn't a political issue except that I
don't like the radical leftists
and their restrictions on pricing.
Thanks [inaudible].
For me,
it's,
it's boundaries for politicians just
started the new things that they don't get
to do it stepping [inaudible] realm or
these fits into the theological realm and
they should stay the hell out of the bowl.
[inaudible]
you're,
you're no longer where you should.
You've transformed yourself into
a target and not a good time.
Not that there is a good content.
So now the consequences are harvest
because I've been objected to that.
Oh,
separately him with a
fair degree of success,
the only response that can be mounted,
listen to this monster,
is this within two,
maybe conceptualizations.
I've got them identity politics.
So it,
since I'm objecting to that,
then I must be the reprehensible engine.
It's like,
well,
good luck the facts.
It's not going to work out
because that is what's going on.
So and so to the 17 year old girl.
It's like,
who knows how many 17 year old girls
are paid attention to what I'm saying on
aging?
I would say it's in the tens of thousands,
perhaps hundreds of thousands.
And so the mere fact that
that isn't the story,
that a small subsection of the ideological
he committed popular media is telling
him to serve.
By no means all of them by any stretch
of the imagination does feed it's
economically true.
So now we might be rare.
Statistically speaking for olds,
listen to me,
I give ever served them all the time.
More power to in as far as I'm concerned,
it's a complicated message.
The lectures are very sophisticated and
difficult and it's great that if you're,
if you happen to find that your
interest is captured by them,
then there's something to that.
What advice would I have for teens?
Like you do what you think's right,
Kiddo.
[inaudible]
in 12 rules.
You mentioned that people can go this
quit your teaching to be hell to pay.
I think I noticed why,
but say why.
Well,
I read a lot of critiques of Carl Young
and he's often accused of doing all of
the malicious things like start to help.
For example.
Are you talking about man,
one of those critiques,
I thought you actually
understood what he was up to.
What you're doing is like accusing
ambassador of chain walking.
What he was doing was so valuable
that like starting a health that's,
that's not even in the
same conceptual universe.
Partly where you'll get to starting
to do is to put the metaphysical
substructure back.
I'm in Western civilization
and to the degree that I'm,
I'm just still,
but he was up doing to development to
something green can be communicated
effectively.
Then there's also what I've been trying
to do for 30 years and I'd be trying to
do it because I studied what I told you
I was studying at the beginning of this
tall.
I looked at the worst things that I
see that people were capable of doing.
And I look at them for a very long time
and I tried to understand why they were
doing and then and they me.
And then I tried to figure
out what the alternative was.
And so I'd be laying on an alternative
because that's what we need to learn for
what happened in the 20th century.
We need to learn the alternative to
what happened in the Soviet Union.
And we need to learn the alternative
to what happened in Nazi Germany.
And listen what happened
in Nazi Germany to have,
and again on this,
we want what happened in the
Soviet Union to happen again.
We need to learn are less and so,
and the lesson is an individual lesson,
not an elective list.
And I believe this to
be empirically the case.
Why is this commentators that I grabbed
on Nazi Germany and the Soviet Union
have all come to the same conclusion.
The reason those tyrannies could exist
and maintain yourselves and then do the
murderous things that they did was
because the individuals that compose those
societies rejected their moral,
individual moral responsibility and
allowing those to test case to take place.
And I believe that to be the case.
I take what you got west.
What we got right in the West is the
idea of that the political system,
the economic system,
the familial system,
all of that rests on your shoulders.
You're corruption corrupts everything.
You're [inaudible] and that's a terrible,
but it also something that
gives you some to take to.
It turns out that you are,
or you might say,
well that's all I ever wanted to know
that I'm important that I haven't put rule
delights like,
yeah,
you better think that
through because there's,
there's two ways this works.
Either you're a Dusko and everything
you do is meaningless and who the hell
cares?
What difference is it going to make it a
million years or everything you do not.
And when you make a mistake,
everything shapes and that's
how you make a mistake.
Everything
[inaudible]
guilty about it.
If that wasn't the case and you do feel
talking about at that guiltless counter
escape from that killed except by
stopping stopping those things.
So it's filtering.
So that's why I say we're going to be
helping people notice what I teach it
because like that's a
hell of a thing to teach.
It's a healthy thing to realize yourself.
It's partly why I'm trying to be careful
with what I say because I've learned
that I should be careful
with what you're saying.
Is it hard for me to be away from my
briefing while my wife's comes along with
me?
So
[inaudible]
patients with her,
which is like a 16 hour a day occupation
because our life is very complicated
and I'm very complicated with
all the complexity and she
also has to put up with me.
That's not an easy thing.
So she's in this heart and soul,
thank God for that
because I couldn't do it.
[inaudible]
they're in it.
They're all attitude where
they know what's going on.
You don't want to spend
more time with them.
When I get home and we get along just
fine and they're supporting what I'm doing
and have been my daughter works for
me full time now and she or kindness,
my schedule that she's quite interesting
creature in your own right because she,
she's back from an absolutely devastating
disease is doing quite well now.
Good,
good.
It's always been good.
Ever since he was a little
kid at why is counseling.
We always listened to him as if he had
something to say and it turned up in
[inaudible].
I,
my computer's
having a small one second.
How long before you do a video
conversation with Kanye West?
It
is helpful.
I mean,
I don't even know what to say about
Candice Owens,
right?
I mean it's just absurd.
So we'll see.
We'll see what happens.
My wife and I are expecting a Sunday,
the 25th you'll be listening to you like
what's your advice on [inaudible] Care
Business?
Well there a chapter in your old 12 call.
Sorry,
chapter
soon that the person
knows something you don't,
okay,
so I'm going to tell the
story about the marriage.
This is tiny.
Cool.
So I had,
this is wild curls.
He went to sweet get married
because he's Swedish,
Swedish Canadian,
and
you're married.
Ceremony.
The apple had to hold
accountable on being married.
You're taking your balances and
that was very interesting to me.
You know,
in the Christian symbolic world,
marriage is a sacrament of the sacred.
What'd you need to do some big acts you
about it can fundamental and knocked to
be mass.
The cows maybe of course.
That's what you assume.
When you take the bottom,
you're going to make this a
foundation that you don't shake.
You found when you were
kind of to yourself on your,
absolutely stayed to yourself on it.
One of the things about God,
and this is worth knowing perhaps,
especially to the people in this
audience who haven't been married yet,
but maybe to those of people
who are already married,
there's an idea which is your marriage
cannot work unless you're all in.
That's,
what about has he falls,
let's say monogamous powers are
very common around the world,
by the way.
I made a lot more the society,
but they tend to be very unstable
for all sorts of complicated reasons.
So there's a strong proclivity towards
social enforcement all coming along and
there's a strong need to make it in viola.
Now there's a psychological
reason for that,
which is that you are not going
to be committed enough to,
your partner will take care of them
unless you bloody well know you wanted to
shut it off without you are shocking
to the inescapable lead for the rest of
your life.
Why are you going to be
serious enough about it?
It's like,
really?
I have to put up with
you for like 50 years.
We better get our in order
because otherwise he's going
to be some spice in hell
because you're just screwed
up in a horrible as Nisha so,
so is that something that's very,
very seriously.
So He'd go with your
partner has a problem.
If you have a problem,
you want to solve that because otherwise
you're going to have it maybe every day
for the rest of your life.
And you might think,
well,
I don't have to because I can
run away and find someone else.
It's like,
well,
good luck with that because they're
going to come with just as many flaws
probably as you have probably as your
partner has given to bring all your
insecurities.
Media sees into the new
relationship anyway,
so listen,
want to be alone,
which is still picking again generally a
fairly quick route to kind of insanity.
Then you're pretty much stuck with the
fact that you have flaws in them anyways,
so they're standing
with this candle bones.
Here's the IBM.
It's the same ideas.
Can't believe Christmas,
so complicated,
but you know something,
you,
most of you act out
in the darkness of the way.
Can you bring the tree inside was what
the hell are you up to if you don't know
what to do it anyways,
but a bunch of lights
in it because of course,
what do you want to do when you bring
the tree in your house and she would
light.
That stands to reason,
right?
And when does it,
like,
you don't know why it was to
symbolize illumination in darkness.
And it's,
it's,
it's a,
it's a pagan ritual,
but it's being Christianized.
You put an angel perhaps if the top of
the tree to signified that which is at
the top of a news and you celebrate the
reemergence of the light and the dark
areas.
So it's a little ritual.
It's 80 back laying up in the world in
terms of good and evil with lightning,
good darkness be evil.
And it's a good thing to do in the
winter because it's dark and you're also
celebrating to be birds of the sonnets.
Very,
very complicated.
So the category in the
tree is a sight and vision,
like it's a Christmas tree.
So it's associated with the idea of the
birth of the mythological hero for the
Messiah.
That's crazy.
And so you're doing all that at the
same time right now for celebration mode
because it's a great thing when
a new hero inches the world.
That's what happens when you give
birth to a child was the child has,
is a locus of divine consciousness is,
is that birth like putting different
logical hero always is because he's small
and fragile and all of that
hopefully goes up to do great things.
So that's all tangled up in that.
So the,
the candle is a simple of the light in
the world and the light in the world is,
but there's a logical here at work,
it's Christ and the Christian drama.
So we'll use that.
So you hold the camera above your head
when you're getting married to symbolize
what you are subordinate to.
Because you might say,
what did the marriage,
well,
the wife is subordinate to the husband.
That's the claim that's put out by
those who think that marriage is a
patriarchal,
oppressive institution,
which it is by the way,
which you know,
because the only people that get married
now are rich people and rich people
don't oppress themselves
as far as we know.
And what if you look at
the demographics chosen,
disintegrated,
it's disintegrated from the
lower socioeconomic classes.
Come up with a reason for why didn't
you privilege people would impress
themselves.
Then the whole notion that
marriage is not oppressive.
Patriarchal structure is
pretty much English proof.
So,
so we'll say,
well,
waves aren't as important
to their husbands,
but we also say husbands aren't
supporting it to the wives as well.
And Fair enough.
So,
so what is it that a couple of subordinate
to and answers what's symbolized by
the light?
And so what that means
now there's an old idea.
It's a very sick boy.
Again,
a weird idea that Christ was androgynous,
a combination of male and female.
He was a reconstruction of the original
Adam who is male and female before he
was pulled apart.
This is a dream,
right?
It's a cultural Greek.
And so praise is the property
union of masculine and feminine.
And so that's where the marriage is.
The property can be that masculine and
feminine and the people in the marriage,
the husband and the wife are supposed
to be subordinate to the ideal union of
masculine and feminine.
And what that idea of union is,
that spirit that's created by proper
and truthful the baby dialogue.
So what you do,
if you,
if you're married to someone,
you have to contend with,
everything,
have to contend with a few.
And that's a real bad if
you're actually communicated,
cause you're not saying that
different personalities,
you have different values,
you have different aims,
are different sections
like you're different.
And that if you could incorporate that
difference of both of you can incorporate
that every time you both why went
out and you're full of flaws and your
partner's full of flaws,
but he knows something you don't
and you know something he does.
And so as you can start
that information exchanged,
going that peripheral dialogue,
then both of you can be transformed me
in the course of the August speech that
constitutes the relationship,
that negotiation and what
you're supposed to do.
And this is what symbolized by the candle
is both subordinate yourself to that
ongoing negotiation.
So you know,
one thing you don't want to do is
don't want to beat your wasting,
even though you already want to.
I mean,
you absolutely want to,
and you're going to act that out too.
And she's going to do
the same thing to you.
It's just not that helpful because
you have to live with her tomorrow.
And so if you'll give
the hearing an argument,
well,
here's the options.
A,
she was writing and you were wrong.
If you just argument better,
and so what the hell
good is that she's right.
You have them solve a problem or you
would write and you need your good.
Then she's like in and
not very happy about it.
Who's gonna do the same thing to you?
As soon as the opportunity arises,
that's not very helpful.
So what do you want to do?
And you want to find out
what the hell the problem is,
which is really painful and horrible
thing to do because people sometimes don't
even know what the coffee is.
And then you have to listen to them like
for three days while they play a lot
with trying to tell you what's wrong
cause they know no and you have to shut up
and not offer solutions too early
because otherwise they can go through the
painful process of figuring
out what the problem is.
Maybe some problem they have with the of
1975 and it takes to get to the bottom
of that.
But if you're,
listen,
if you listen,
knowing that if you solve the problem,
you don't have to have any again,
then you can get that negotiated
dialogue going continually.
And that's what you're
supposed to be subordinate to.
And so then to answer this question,
which is get back to appearance,
my wife and I are spending the summer
in 25th one group advice on telling sick
childcare,
marriage and business.
It's like,
well my advice is
stick to your damn cow.
So you can't run away and then continue
with your wife because the two of you
have you do brings rather than one who
probably be able to figure out how to do
this as you go.
If you actually talk to each other.
That's part of the utility of free speech
that you give to think out loud and if
there's someone else around you is also
thinking and whose life is intertwined
with yours and you both
Amy from what's good,
then between the you might be
able to get the process going.
That's the,
that's the exchange of the logos,
let's say.
That will enable you to overcome the
problems of life and then maybe have you
done that.
You'll make yourself into a unit,
a reasonably intelligent,
wise.
It's also capable of learning.
And then when your child
encounters that unit,
there'll be a nice wall around them.
You know,
you know what?
Kids are like this.
They're,
they're,
they're pushy little prime next and
they'll do everything they can to find a
hole in the wall.
They'll just purchase the torture.
With George,
he sees me as a weakness
somewhere they want to know.
And if they can set you against your wife,
they will absolutely do that.
But if you,
because why wouldn't they?
Because they want to see what's real.
They're not messing around
or trying to live right.
And they want to see what's real and then
they're going to push the boundaries.
And if you have a solid relationship
and the kid comes up and pushes against
that,
it's like,
no,
how could you talk?
Or we're going to walk once or twice.
So stand up underneath a table.
It's too short and
snappy is had a good one.
But because of the table
never changes shape.
He'll only do that once.
And so now if we change,
he was changing shape all the time
where the kid would be underneath there
trying to bang his head on it nonstop.
So if you and your wife has forged a
unit that that isn't editable in some
sense,
then they're going to push and push until
they find out that that doesn't work.
And to play that game anymore.
And that's going to be really good for
you because then your children will
tortured to death and it's really
going to be good for your child because
they're going to have tested the limits
and find out that there are walls to
keep the chaos out and that's going to
make me feel secure and then they're
going to be able to develop
within that security.
So that's a perfect deal.
And so that's fine advice
or you was happy summer
[inaudible]
how should I structure my future
children's education fully prepared for
[inaudible] and respect their culture?
Well,
one of the things that you
might want to think through,
I have a chapter
that children do anything
that makes you dislike them.
And I thought about lecturing
about that tonight too.
It's kind of a dark chapter as well.
I guess maybe the whole book is like that
locally.
The more you're able to
confront the darkness,
the more people are likely to assume
that you have something to say.
I would say because it's,
you have every reason to shy away
from the dark every reason and so,
and everyone knows how dark life can be.
And so if you pretended
that it sounds like that,
then why should anyone listen to you?
I mean,
I know what life was like.
I've spent $20,000
counseling people through.
The most difficult thing is sometimes
that were so difficult that I couldn't
help.
I know they would just,
I couldn't,
I couldn't help them solve a problem,
even with the best of
willow in their apartment.
And we're just cornered.
And there was no damn way out.
It was very,
very bad.
But most of the time it was
a very positive experience
because very frequently
people,
even in dire straits
can make advice along.
So,
but to do that,
well,
you have to have to confront
what's terrible about life.
Life is tragic events by level.
And so you have to be
able to deal with that.
So
how's your destruction?
What would your children's education?
Well,
the first thing that'll EMC
back into little five hour look,
the reason you don't want to
let the children do anything
that makes you dislike
or just because you'll be needing,
if you don't like that and you're way
bigger than them and you're really capable
of being needy and you might
be mean because it's like
you're the sort of person
who abuses your child physically lash out.
You have a terrible temper and your
Anglian Emily May succeeded her brutal or
you might get a sort of person that
smothers dependent law and either way you
can just do that again and you can do
both of those unbelievably mean and if you
don't make the children,
that is exactly what you
do and you might take off.
No,
you won't get he loved all.
It's like,
yes it will happen.
That's when people are like,
and that's why families are often such
snake heads of catastrophe and they don't
have to be like a frequently are and
lots of people's whole life turning his
fight their way home to
unbelievably pathological family.
That's the whole Freud in nightmare.
I'm not sure.
So
you want to encourage your children to
behave in a manner that makes you deeply
appreciate the fact that they exist.
Now you're kind of,
because you're only one person and so
hopefully you have someone around you that
your longterm partner,
let's say,
who can slap it on the back of the
head when you're being too insane.
Because you know,
part of what might make you
dislike your children's,
the fact that you just don't have your
act together very well and they're doing
perfectly okay things if
you happen to be irritated.
And so that's partly why you need a
partner can sort of alerted to when you're
being unreasonable about your demand.
And hopefully the two of
you were different enough.
So you're in Melville,
one to half decent sequent together
person and that person helped you.
Did y'all learn how to be likable?
So other people like them.
So the first thing you want to say grout,
if you want your child to have
a proper relationship with Ba,
etc. Is whether that's
actually what you want.
You know,
because you might be able to,
of course,
that's what people want for the children.
It's like,
no,
not of course.
And it's not what we have.
Lots of people have terrible parents and
they're not just fair to neglect mean
that's bad,
but it's not.
That's only where that starts at neglect.
The kids can handle that.
It's movies,
it's not total.
But like I've had clients
whose parents did.
Every time that person did something good,
their parents punished every single
time until they were terrified of doing
anything at all.
And even punish them by
criticizing them to death.
And they had the goal to try
to do something useful in
the world or acting as if
they were absolutely terrified and
stole every type of child took a risk,
which is the sort of helicopter parenting
that so absolutely catastrophic,
but don't upset your mother,
you know,
with your courageous and
forthright action in the world.
Right.
And so then see if you knew that they
can associate courageous auction with
guilt.
If you really want to give
it to your kids and have not,
it's an excellent trick.
You take the best thing about them
and make it feel horrible about it,
that's a good trick.
And if you don't take
your capable of that,
then you're not taking it
because you aren't capable of it.
And to real danger.
It's the danger of over protected,
which cause it takes a
real courageous parent too.
It's so interesting.
I watched this video last night,
my wife should be,
to me,
I think it was from Russia.
I don't think this could have ever
possibly happen with North America.
This kid was about to,
I think still in diapers,
pretty mobile.
And the in parents that put up when
those little doorways that you put up for
kids in the door that keeps them in the
room or maybe stops falling down the
stairs.
And so had one of those little
things that were in the doorway.
There was actually two of them on top
of each other because this kid have
learned how to climb up the attic,
like to and learned how
to quiet the little,
the little door with them as
opposed to another one on top.
And he climbed up that up too.
But he's having a hell of a fine time
falling over the top and he was in
diapers.
And look at that.
You think that because
of what's been happening,
but the parents didn't interfere.
They videotaped it.
It's like,
no,
it's not what's abusive.
Here's what's abusers is you.
When you come to kid,
he's three quarters of the way up.
The second one,
so like five feet off the ground and
then you have a little panic attack about
how dangerous it is.
So then you went to Sanford child,
so that all and hurts himself and then
you'd tell them that's what happens when
you do that sort of thing.
That's a user and they didn't do them.
[inaudible] masquerade and he's like,
it's a courageous parent who stands doc.
And I think so,
you know,
I don't want that kid to fall,
but I'm not getting a
fuck about these zones.
They're like master new world.
So naturally to do,
if you have some courage and you
let your children take your lumps,
if you don't have lumps,
are going to get blocked beginning.
So,
so you decide you want the
best for your children.
And you've got to ask yourself
that question seriously
because there's at least,
there's a big part of that Katie part,
let's say it does not appoint
the business with your children.
That would be annoyed
if they were successful.
It would be unhappy with me.
Succeed and so,
and if you don't think that's true that
you do not know anything before because
it is true and PB had
everyone's like that.
Some people are really like that.
So when you mentioned cubs dark,
it doesn't matter.
It's real easy to start
[inaudible].
What would you say to someone who doesn't
feel like enough while you're right,
right.
That's okay.
What you should do is beat
yourself up because of that.
Like you're not enough and you shouldn't.
You shouldn't think you are.
You can think,
what the hell are you?
Are you going to you?
If you're already a candy bowl,
you have nothing to do.
You know,
one of the things that I
noticed it talking to audiences
like this over the last
year and a half,
the audience is very quiet.
When I talk about two things.
One is responsibility and Ruben,
who's quiet.
That's so cool.
Cause Grips,
PE know it's like well
there's something to that.
And you know that in
an audience was quiet,
we were talking comes up,
you know there's something in the air,
it's an unspoken necessity,
it's manifested itself,
it's that and
this issue of self esteem.
So what I'm suggesting to people,
psychologists,
bless her soul that
aren't very well informed,
have been telling people for five decades
that he should have high self esteem.
It's like,
hey,
most of what passes for self esteem as
mentioned by psychologist is actually a
temperamental trait.
So if you take self esteem
scales and you score high,
it's because you're extroverted
and low in neuroticism.
So the scales are wrong.
So that's one.
And number two is [inaudible] says
you should have high self esteem.
What's so great about you and you think,
well that's a terrible
thing to tell people.
It's like going snow on because people
aren't very happy with who they are.
And so if you tell them,
oh no,
you're good the way you argued.
Wait a second,
I'm not happy with the
way things are with me.
And so I'm supposed to be
happy with the way I am.
Then like what about all this misery?
That's part of my life.
And so it's not a good thing to tell
people that they're just okay the way they
are.
That's not good at all.
What do you want to tell them is
you could be way more than you are.
You could be way more than you are.
And that would be that.
That would be better for you and it
would be better for your families,
would be better for the country,
be better for everyone.
And there's something about
insufficient and wretchedness war.
They did start that,
start on that pathway
and be successful at it.
And so it isn't that you should be
that you should be happy with yourself
because of who you are.
It's that you should be respectful of
yourself because you are the sort of
person who could transform
herself into who you could be.
And now it's way better.
And so [inaudible] want to put
a little bit boundary rub that,
look,
I know that people can
be themselves often.
They do that all the time.
And so you can be too judgmental
with regards to yourself.
And that leads to depression and
high levels of anxiety can be really
destructive and can culminate
suicide like you got to,
despite the fact that you're
not everything you could be,
you have to have a little bit of mercy
that you're touch towards yourself.
You don't want to,
you don't want it.
You want to treat yourself with
someone that you're trying to help.
Right?
That's another rule.
And you talk to us for life.
Treat yourself like you're someone
you're responsible for helpful.
And that would be hard
as it bit of detachment.
Imagine that you're worthwhile despite
your anatomy nurses and they've your
necessary in the world at least
as a bulwark against help.
And I think that's absolutely the case
because you could certainly generate a
little held on yourself
without too much effort.
So you could at least not do
that and that might be important.
So it's reasonable to treat yourself
with a certain amount of detached with
respect and then to regard yourself as,
so when you should try to help.
Like you would help someone who can
carry forward in a detached sort of way.
Because if people have value,
if other people have value that you have
value and you open yourself the safe,
ethical responsibility that you will
welcome people and maybe what you will
other people is the responsibility to
help move along the way so that the world
gets better,
relevant works.
And so that's the same attitude
that you should make yourself.
So despite the fact that we are all
making showed me and despite the fact that
you have plenty to allergic
and you should learn,
there you go.
You also don't get to beat yourself to
death with a stick all the time because
you're insufficient in 15 different ways.
So justice,
that's the,
and mercy is what people seem
to tolerate the children.
And you need to use disposable.
That was in order to establish the
proper relationship with your life.
And so you're not enough and say going
for that cause you wouldn't have anything
worthwhile to do if you were enough and
you do have something worthwhile to do,
which is to make things better
than they are of yourself.
And so do it.
[inaudible]
do you pray?
Well,
I don't know.
I don't ask God for famous.
Right?
And I think that's what people do,
that the prayer
prayer is actually something that works,
but ask them for favors with God.
That doesn't work because
that is how it works.
He couldn't ask to have enough
courage to see the truth.
And that's a painful thing to do.
So for example,
here's a,
here's a prayer of sorts.
It's imagine you're hugging the site guys,
your white,
and it's not a good fight.
It's this sort of fight that makes you
wonder whether you should be it the damn
relationship.
And so every fight contending that
direction is often quite people won't have
fights because we can open up
that entire space of catastrophe.
And it's partly why you want
to be serious about your vows.
You don't want to open up the possibility
that you can leave every time you have
a fight.
I mean,
good God,
you really want that choice.
What that 40 day.
It's not,
that's not freedom.
It's just chaos has some choices you
don't want to have to make all the time.
It was hard enough to figure
out that you should get married.
You're,
you want to choose whether or not you're
going to stay married every day because
that's just not good.
So,
so anyway,
let's say you're having a fight with your
wife and it's Brooklyn and you want to
win and the notion was
wrong and he liked it,
a theater and all of that,
and you get to the addictive about
it and she's seeing the same thing.
And so it's sort of
spiraling out of control.
And so here's something you can do.
You can go your separate ways momentarily
and you can sit on the edge of your
bed and you think,
okay,
I probably did something outstanding,
stupid in the last three months.
Then increased the probability that
you're having this terrible fight.
I'd probably get some,
what was it?
But you have to want to go down cause
that's the prayer that's knocking on the
door.
We'll right ask and you
will receive this like one,
it depends on when you ask for.
So if you ask from what
would be best for you,
maybe you'll get it.
That doesn't mean that you'll like it.
And so if you sit on the edge
of your bed and you think,
okay,
in my maybe a seat,
what did I do to contribute
to this horrible fight?
You sit there two or three minutes
actually wanting to build the answer,
which you will know cause you
don't want them to answer.
You'll get it.
You'll get an answer just
as clear as could be.
You'll think,
oh yeah,
that's what I did.
That was,
and then you'll think,
well that's when county,
that's only contributing
5% of the problem.
She's still 99% of lane.
It's like,
yeah,
maybe guardian to 5%
so that's been enough.
And then you can go back to her and
maybe she's done the same thing and she
could tell you what,
she's an idiot.
Then you could tell her when you're an
Indian and then you two idiots might be
able to have a conversation
and solve the problem.
And that's a prayer.
And that work.
If you want to know why you're
stupid and you ask yourself,
you will get announced.
And that's prayer.
[inaudible]
the one more in entire,
I don't want to say anything stupid.
What do I think of polygamy?
Give me personally or
I think that it's,
it leads to unstable societies.
It leads to unhappy,
resentful,
aggressive,
angry men.
Because there are men
who don't have any women.
And that leads to the
stabilization of society.
It's a bad idea,
which is why you see a strong proclivity
towards monogamy among human cultures.
It's a clinic.
You know what I mean?
People are capable and willing to
engage in polygamous relationships.
All things considered.
It's a bad solution,
right?
So what does all things considered me?
Well,
you've got to think,
well,
what's good for you right now?
What?
He might take unlimited
sexual opportunity right now.
So it doesn't take much
thinking to understand.
Probably probably that that's
not a very sophisticated and so,
but if you're describing certs,
it might seem attractive.
What's good for you right now,
which is good for you right now in a way,
this good for you with a week,
it's good for you to month
it's been for you in 10 years is
continue across your lifespan.
What is,
well,
we'll kind of know this
probably better not to be alone.
It's probably better to have someone
with you through your life because all
things considered,
it works better.
Now that doesn't mean it's a picnic or
that it's easy for any of those things,
but of course it doesn't.
Of course not.
And then it isn't just
put your finger for you,
it's which bigger for your family.
The evidence for that children is crystal
clear and I can't believe we even have
this discussion in our society.
It's like other families in our work.
Well that doesn't mean that all families
without fathers are catastrophes and it
doesn't get that all families
with one if they're successful,
but the evidence is quite clear.
It looks to be like the nuclear family
is the minimal viable social unit.
Now extended families,
they have the pros and the cons and
maybe a also worker but you can't get it
smaller than husband and
wife and have things work.
That's what it looks like.
And I think the psychological
literature on that is quite clear.
So can I just get a conversation by the
way with word Fairport who wrote a book
called the boy crisis and another book
called why men earn more than both of
those books are for three and Pharaoh
and I have a nice discussion about the
role that for this plate he really
illuminated something to be,
he said that his research and indicated
Amnon is primary research review of the
research that what fathers do.
This was so cool cause it's so smart.
I knew already that father's engage in
rough and tumble play with their kids to
go to it to a higher proportion of degree.
Women do too,
but not as much as men tend to do it more.
And I knew that rough and tumble play
and that kind of exciting exploratory
physical play was necessary
for the development,
not only of children of animals as well.
You'll see the same thing happening with
wraps for example and other sorts of
mammals.
They engaging couple of plates for
all sorts of reasons and so that helps
children understand that when things are,
when they don't get what
the extent of the body is,
what's exciting about play and how to
trust someone when the stakes are rather
highlight when you'd be thrown in the
air and all of these things and how to
take turns if you're playing with
multiple kids at the same time,
how not to stick your thumb in your
father's eye and what still finding what's
exciting and all of these things that
are very complex and sophisticated and
humble.
Glade does that in children love it work
like mad and engaging and fathers would
you'd like it to and it tends to
terrify mothers because mothers are very
tightly bonded with their children,
especially when they're young.
They tend to be more
on the protective side.
How sticky that way.
So there has to be that guy now,
but by Farrell said something
very interesting which
was that his understanding
is it would fathers do to
scaffold delay of gratification,
which if that sacrificial
attitude we already talking about,
you know,
do something that you don't want to do
now is difficult and don't impulsively
rewarding so that the future
will be mattered and sort
of the basis of civilized
endeavor.
Fundamentally it's the attitude
that's necessary for work.
Pharaohs notion was that father scaffolded
that by using play as a reward for
delay of gratification so far doesn't
play with your kids and then that would be
enough for you.
Kids want to keep playing
in the folks and look,
you know you can't play all the time.
Cool,
clean up your room,
go do your homework,
go set the table,
go do this little task,
whatever it is and then we'll place.
I thought,
God,
that's so smart because you want to use
a prime member of the board source to
scaffold them.
Delayed gratification can use food.
That's what you scratch
and allowed for example,
but does not a great morning for kids.
Only you can use it for your
toilet train for example,
can be very effective.
But that idea that what what fathers do
is use play as a scaffold for teaching
delay of gratification.
I thought that was plugging really is.
And so anyways,
we had quite a lengthy discussion
about the role of fathers.
So,
uh,
let me see here.
Now this is why I have to stop because
I'm forgetting what the questions are
now.
So,
Oh yes,
I was
so,
so the reason that you set up among
the monogamous relationships as well,
it's not going to be that it's good for
you and your future self and your wife
and her future self and
you as a comparable,
but because it's good for your kids.
And I think part of the reason that you
take the narrative about was because
that's the best thing for children.
And once you have children,
it's not about you anymore.
It's not spoken kit.
So,
and that I think if the hallmark
of adult responsibility,
and so play to me is not,
it's not commensurate
with a fully functional,
civilized society and it tends to
be generated to anarchic violence.
And so most cultures evolve
away from it quite wrapping up.
So that's that.
And so thank you very much.
[inaudible].